well guys i am back i survived
a coordinated
relentless effort to destroy this show
and i'll tell you what i had a great
week doing it
oh great week off
so shout out to all
of the sappy eyed
stomping tantrum babies
who got us suspended for a week you guys
have a good week yeah i had a lot of fun
yeah a great week oh yeah
well rested
i actually have a lot to talk about but
before we do i gotta first of all give a
quick thank you to hellofresh
looking for a stress-free summer
hellofresh sent you
fool proof
step-by-step recipes and fresh
pre-portioned ingredients to make meal
time a summer breeze get 16 free meals
plus three free gifts with code h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv 16.
thank you thank you
also quick shout out to teddy fresh this
shirt i'm completely alone an original
uh eloquent art which is keying out
currently
but if you go to teddy fresh this and a
bunch of other really cool shirts are
there it's summer so get those t-shirts
now thank you
all right
wow what a week you know
i'll tell you guys what
first of all i'll say this
i'm not mad that youtube banned us for a
week i get it you know i get it
so
the other thing i'll say this
but to be honest i was afraid it was
going to go worse i thought it was at
first when i saw
you know don jr tweeted about it and
alex jones and all these conservatives
on
the whole cons conservo sphere
was you know tweeting this 10-second
clip of me saying
uh someone should b word that
building
because that's fair right i don't want
to say it because you know i got banned
last time
um
in my craft
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
yeah i don't i i probably shouldn't say
but um
i was afraid it might actually get worse
like i was like [ __ ] this is bad i don't
know i was afraid we might get like this
whole channel demonetized or
you know how sometimes when something
really bad happens with like logan paul
or it happened with shane
too where their channel gets like
demonetized for three months or
something or like i don't know some
undisclosed amount of time
so i was i was
i was pretty nervous i'm not gonna lie
um but
um
but it didn't you know it was just so it
was just a seven week suspension and
everything's fine seven day seven days
seven weeks seven day
you know so that was a relief i was
scared i'm not gonna lie there was so
many death threats and anti-semitic
crazy
flipping nuttiness coming my way i was a
little scared it was a tense week
in some senses because
you just never know man people are
people say crazy [ __ ] online you know
die
i i'll be honest too i had a wendy
williams moment i think
because you know when she goes uh
death to all of them and then she
shocked herself
i think i had that i think i
i i you guys are kindred spirits for
sure i i never thought i would say it
but i think we had we i had a wendy
williams moment there death to all of
them no i think you too really you have
a cosmic connection you think so
well you're both
farting all the time and uh right
farting and burping and talking about k
wording people
yeah you know okay wording okay
first of all i said be the building not
k the people so true right that's a very
important yeah
death to all of them but here's what so
just to explain because i watched that
clip back you know
first of all it was funny i'm not even
gonna deny it okay
there was a meme on this subreddit
that was like the joker me maybe you can
pull it up and someone's like i'm tired
of pretending what ethan said wasn't
funny
that's a good one to tweet out love
it was funny man
just because it was so it was so
ridiculous and i was thinking like okay
all those people
all those terrible people are in one
building
and i was thinking like how are we gonna
get these people to actually care about
this and it's like bring the heat to
their now obviously a joke okay not
serious guys
i'm i'm clenching a little bit
i'm just explaining my rationale i know
because it was like
you know how do we make them care about
they're so pro second amendment let's
see what happens when the second
amendment comes to them not a serious
suggestion to anyone i was obviously
very angry i have two young kids in the
wake of
just a horrible a traumatic just just
disgusting
what happened in uvalde and you know i'm
still angry about it
i'm still so angry about it and like i
just saw my news feed in texas where
this took place just to show you i mean
this is what we're up against guys
they're passing legislation here let me
pull this up to ban
kids
from
make it illegal
for kids to be in the presence of of a
drag show like that's what they're
thinking about right now
it's it's bananas you guys it's
[ __ ] outrageous and the only thing i
regret is that i became like this uh
this useful talking point for all the
reactionaries that want to
you know change the conversation
from
a just horrific tragic
thing that happened there
and the obvious need for action
turned into
a conversation about liberals are like
dangerous and and like
uh violent because i made a stupid joke
um
what a loving liberal yeah that's alex
shawn's talking about me and we'll get
into all that of course
but um
did you find that meme
it was like right when it happened but
you know
um
i watched that clip back and i'm like
dude this is funny this is just it's
obvious so funny how we rolled it back
and we were laughing about it like
you know zach clearly the the
reactionaries who were angry didn't hear
that we played the will smith rewind
time sound by otherwise they would know
yeah
they must have missed that because that
that
you could say whatever you want as long
as you exactly
yeah dude zach dropped that it's rewind
time sound bite so fast i was like i was
laughing bro so hard and the record
scratch and everything
it's so funny
yeah that cl exonerates everything what
is going on outside it sounds like
someone's about the b word our building
uh oh they're coming for you dude what
the hell
that is the loudest yeah
someone landing on the roof it sounds
like there's a helicopter like 10 feet
above the building i they just flew off
but
uh oh i think we're about to get air
striked jeez
that was scary i don't you guys probably
i don't know if you could hear but we're
all like a little scared right now that
was that was really close yeah it felt
like it was really close okay well it's
gone
uh
so anyway um die
yeah i had a wendy william moment but
someone's got to find that
it's back there and it's so good
but actually first before i want to talk
about all the insane
over-the-top
bananas reactions that people had to it
i want to talk about my incredible
week-long vacation
compliments
of the lunatics you know what's weird uh
oh here did someone find it
oh i think so olivia came through
wait no
no no
all right i'll keep it it's the joker
meme where it's like i'm tired of
pretending like it's not funny
yeah so the crit the weird thing is that
the minute the show ended
we snipped out the part of me saying be
the building
snipped it out
was probably gone from the episode
within like 30 minutes after
the live ended
it it took a it takes longer than that
to process the edit but probably a few
hours
okay
and so
we were like well maybe we'll maybe
we'll be fine because
because uh oh thank you here fine yeah
here we go thank you kim
thank you karen here this is this is the
meme i was talking about that's 2 000
points let me get this straight you
think what ethan said was funny i do
when i'm tired of pretending it's not
you know it was kind of nice to be like
under the
this intense mic canceling my microscope
but for the first time all of our fans
were on my side
i don't think that's ever happened
before when i get into trouble usually
everyone's angry at me
so that was a nice change you know
so my joker brain slash goblin people
were saying i'm in goblin mode because i
was tweeting all kinds of crazy [ __ ] too
when i break i was just like i was yep i
was relentless
and you know
people were so angry i just thought it
was a funny
opportunity
to uh
here let me read some and i think i have
some interesting insight
but what i was gonna say is it it got
removed for bullying and harassment so i
was like we cut the b the building part
and i saw some of the conservatives were
angry about my jokes about greg abbott
like putting a stick in his spokes and
that to me is the funniest [ __ ] thing
because they're they're just such
hypocrites they're the biggest
snowflakes in the world dude you can't
handle a stupid joke about putting a
stick in a spoke and so i wonder if
that's what they ended up removing it
for
because we sniffed i don't know i don't
know the real reason it could have been
it could have been one or the other
why am i on oh this is me by the way
quick shot look at this photo shoot
turned out so sick look at that
for teddy fresh
gym collection
how dope is that
that's awesome so cool thank you guys
thanks
yeah it turned out so sick so there you
have that
all right let's see my goblin mode
tweets people were loving this
on the subreddit anyway not so much on
twitter
um
i'm not gonna read this one
some of these are too spicy for youtube
twitter don't care about anything bro
wait
wait what
where is the
um
[Music]
so i'm not reading that one
that one's too hot for tv
i'm not maybe just not any of them no
some of them are good some of them are
good okay
some of them are really good
trust me
they're still scrolling
so this one i said question for all the
pant [ __ ]
losers who have been reporting me to the
police
for my very credible bomb threats beef
threats oh were they supposed to have
interrogated me by now because nothing's
happened it seems like pretty obvious to
them it was a joke dang that's
crazy and to everyone who's been
lobbying to get me banned on youtube for
being a domestic t word try harder
losers i'm joined my one one week
vacation though slept in today
um
there was one other one i was going in
for greg abbott and i learned something
really interesting about
greg abbott that i think you guys will
like
so greg abbott and i'm not saying this
to to bully him i just think it's
interesting he's a religious man
obviously and the texans are religious
people
so i was wondering how did he get
paralyzed
and do you and i swear to god this is
true the man was jogging and a tree fell
on him
if that's not an act of god i don't know
what the [ __ ] is bro a tree just fell on
him that's like straight out of a
cartoon when like zeus throws a
lightning bolt and a tree just like bro
god was clearly trying to kill him is
what i'm saying
that's right i said let's be honest
you know
it's a sign from god
abbott is the road runner except he's in
a wheelchair obviously and god is coyote
except he's more confident because he
did paralyze greg and the spirit
people did not like that tweet
but i do want to i do want to be clear
that i i want to disavow the ableism
aspect of this
because first of all there's nothing
wrong with being a wheelchair we love
our people in the wheelchair what i'm
saying
is that god hates greg abbott and he
tried to kill him and failed
therefore he's in a wheelchair not
saying that that there's anything wrong
with that based on their logic not that
you believe that
people who suck can be in wheelchairs
like he is a person who sucks there's
always wheelchairs
good
people bad people mm-hmm mobility
married somewhere in between maybe
chaotic
this person this person who sucks if
you're sitting in the wheelchair
but i'm not i'm not as interested in the
wheelchair aspect just about how god
obviously tried to kill him and it's
possible the devil's the one that
intervened to save him and therefore
greg abbott
bidding in the world if i'm a christian
right i'm looking at that i'm like yo
a log fell on this man when he was
jogging this is the governor of texas by
the way he's a vile demon
uh he's a demon see i didn't know that
when i was reading your tweet i thought
you were just making up a scenario no no
no okay no that's [ __ ] how he got
paralyzed it's nuts i mean who does that
happen to watch a demon die
i mean yeah exactly this is i was just
went down to greg abbott meme hole and i
saw this headline governor greg abbott
this is where
uvalde is he attributes the mass
s-wording to mental health issues
a month after cutting 211 million
dollars from mental health commission
it's like the man is a vile demonic
pos okay
oh and then people were saying that we
faked our donations
we we ended up raising like 120 000 for
the families
via our stop our gun reform now shirt
that ela made
there was like people was it keemstar i
know quartering was doing all kinds of
people were saying we faked it
because we it went up and then it
disappeared because dude it was a 50
dollar donation it takes time to
to confirm that i don't know about keem
but yeah i saw the quartering no keem
was okay which is oh that's surprising
yeah surprising that keem would
publicly try and question you about
where some money went right that's
that's why i thought he was not the
first time and by the way did you think
that it's just a little odd that i me
okay
i'm always being questioned about what
about making fun doing financial frauds
even though i've never ever done
anything like that proven
it's like do you find it just a little
bit [ __ ] odd that i'm constantly
getting called out for financial fraud
do you think it's because
you are overweight
it might be because i'm fat
but you guys see what i'm saying like
it's so [ __ ] blatantly obvious to me
that these people
are literally just
playing to the fact that i'm jewish to
oh jewish
it's like they're literally they're so
obviously just perpetuating anti-semitic
uh tropes about me even though i have
never ever done that no matter what i do
i do a good thing i get called out for
it every [ __ ] time we raise a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars for the
family you could go there it's on
gofundme it's on the top list same thing
with the lawsuit you know philip
defranco made a gofundme for me that i
didn't even ask for or want and uh i get
called for [ __ ] stealing money i mean
the whole thing is insane also when you
say donated for the pandemic same thing
when you're oh yeah same thing oh yeah i
gave away a hundred thousand dollars of
my own money for the pandemic people
were saying it's fake the same people as
always it's [ __ ] you know it's like dude
i i don't know what more i can do
millions of jews
yes keemstar is the most surprising too
because you'd think
you'd think that he'd learn his lesson
because that
whole accusation about the fupafun thing
was really the breaking point when you
ended up making a four-hour documentary
about what a giant piece of [ __ ] he is
well he didn't learn his lesson because
even though he literally quite literally
defamed me the video's still up on his
channel and nobody gives a [ __ ] except
me right
all these commentary channels that like
co-signed it and put it out there and
said i'm a scammer and a fraud
luckily we're able to dispel that but
yeah
and then this guy we're going to watch
this video later i'm just there's so
much on my mind
this guy called the [ __ ] we're going
to watch this whole video about here
just to give you a little tip
yes ma'am um i just returned from the
nra annual meeting in houston texas at
the george r brown convention center
and uh while i was in there there was a
person online his name is ethan klein he
was on a podcast and he made the comment
that someone shouted
yeah so he's calling the department the
texas department of public safety on me
saying he has a credit a credible threat
of i heard somebody on podcast there's
something i figured a lot my favorite
part is he goes
i got home safely and it was a week ago
but i think it's a credible threat
this guy's such a yeah his channel by
the way is called uh
legally armed american yeah legally
armed and triggered as hell
you know why this guy owns so many guns
because he's a [ __ ] baby
he's scared all the time
i guess that is why people do own guns
actually on ironically
but um i can't wait to watch this video
with you guys it's such a it's such a
it's a beta of him to own so many guns
it is kind of beta to own so many guns
it's like dude
what are you're obviously compensating
who needs like a thousand guns
so anyway um let's talk so during my
week we're gonna get into all that
my week off was crazy dude
first of all as some of you many of you
guys may have seen on social media i was
reunited
at long last
with my friend and friend of the show
post malone whose album just came out by
the way 12 carat
toothache
which you guys should stream now
and we got invited to um
his listening party
by the way this was and it was crazy it
was so so dope britney was there
oliver was there
this what's his name tyga
or what's his name oh swally that's wali
right
sway lee
i don't even notice that
he's super nice by the way he's a really
cool guy
um
i think i can hear you typing
love is that love type thing yeah i'm
turning him down
but like i was hanging out with all the
with all these guys all night and it was
like so much fun it was just so cool i
spent the whole
evening with oliver
britney was there like half the night
and it was so fun hanging out with her
she's the best she's amazing
austin was so fun to hang out with
amazing i was with oliver and austin all
night we went back to
to uh
me and uh oliver went back to austin's
house after and we were just hanging out
all night it was great it was so much
fun
such a nice thing and i didn't know but
oliver and austin have a cute
relationship too
um
oliver's so fun i did we have like this
this dumb beef but
he's such a sweetheart and such a
character whoa
such a character you guys but the crazy
thing
all right so i'm gonna there's something
happened there i'm going to say this and
i don't want to
some oh it's yeah it's
wait it's ya
what did you type tyler
swat is it not swally no i played
someone else wait who's this
i'm not familiar i love you man
what you met him well
we were yeah no i didn't yeah i thought
it was sway lead
it's not the sunflower guy
[ __ ]
wait
doesn't he look just like this sunflower
guy oh no he doesn't [ __ ]
it's a different person yeah who's sam
you probably just mixed him up because
they both collabed with foes
i don't know who any of the three people
that you mentioned are so i am of no
help
they're musical artists obviously yeah i
got them that yeah
so anyway um
i don't want to incriminate anyone
so i'm just going to tell this in a way
that
it's just about me okay i'm not saying
anyone else was doing it this is just
what happened
is that somebody there
passed me
okay this is this trip me out
pass me a box of gummies that had
mushrooms in it
and the craziest part about it this was
like a box
it had nutritional information on it do
you know what i'm saying like this was
like manufactured
and i'm like yo what like is it legal
anywhere i just didn't understand how
how
i got that it was like a gummy pack
and it had like eight gummies that
looked like brains tasted great by the
way i took mushrooms once it tastes like
[ __ ] i just ate i just
put a handful of mushrooms and chewed it
like gnarly let's go
this was a whole different thing but
i wasn't i didn't get like super blasted
but i was probably like
a little bit tripping balls to be honest
and so there was a couple of crazy
things there and by the way i haven't
done anything like this in like probably
decades and it was this
it was like this cosmic uh
coincidence where i could do something
like that because
we had a babysitter there who's gonna be
there all night
it was on thursday we didn't have a show
on friday which that never happens
and the kids were sleeping and we're
like dude this is like the first time we
could do this in a decade
so me and eli just
we bought i'll tell you we both did it
dude oh yeah
did you bring enough back for the class
yeah actually i brought a ton back and i
threw it out because i didn't want to do
it
i had a full unused pack bruh i know but
i was like i don't i don't want to do i
don't want to be tempted to take this
again because yeah we'll take it off
your hands i threw it out i'm sorry guys
i threw it yeah we would properly
dispose it before i you know what i'm
sorry guys that could what if somebody
digs through the trash you got to make
sure no it wasn't and also i was scared
of storing it in the house because
theodore loves gummies and i was like ah
well yeah i mean i was gonna store it
like in my gun safe somewhere i knew he
was gonna but i don't know i was just
feeling super paranoid about it
the shrooms and the gun just hanging out
well i was like where is he definitely
not gonna get these
[Music]
by the way we had his third birthday
party too which was super fun but
anyway um
so
and i have to say like you know don't do
this stuff
it's not for everyone
don't do it because i said i did it
never ever do it death yeah yeah well
that's going a bit far
but uh anyway
what was crazy is
um the minute it started to hit me
i was in the bathroom
and i get i'm checking twitter
and i get a message from tony
glory and gold you guys probably
remember him rs gloria gold he's the guy
that keemstar
falsely accused of being a p word
and like ruined his life
he's the runescape player uh guy
he message i'm saying just coming up
right
and i get a message from tony that says
quote
i'm dying very soon
can i call you i was like what
[ __ ]
i was not ready for that that is so i
talked to tony for like an hour
he about how he has brain cancer
that's horrible yeah obviously you know
shout out to tony and everything or like
you know hard thoughts and prayers and
all that
but i was trying to that comes across
pretty insincere
given the context of what we're
well
uh
i'm getting i'm getting to tony okay i
mean you talked to him for an hour so
obviously you uh you know
i'm just saying the hearts the thoughts
and prayers thing is like well i did
more than that obviously
he eventually we got talking about he
wanted help with uh starting a gofundme
so we got it set up here i donated a
thousand bucks already
because like he got so he has brain
terminal brain cancer
and um
he doesn't want to like
leave his family with a bunch of debt
and stuff which is insane only in
america only
in america
i said to him i was like damn dyn's
expensive
kind of funny but kind of not right
so um we'll drop the link
we'll drop the link in the description
and the uh
chat
but yeah if you guys want to support
tony
our good man tony
he's got to go find me now no it's
chad's asking not rollo tony no no no no
i don't care that i can die broke i
don't give a [ __ ]
so but anyway
laughing yes it is it was just it was
just trippy i mean i literally was
coming up i opened my phone and i saw it
typing and i just saw the message like
click through
i was like what the [ __ ] dude
so i was talking with tony while blasted
on mushrooms bro are you [ __ ] high
right now
well about dying and [ __ ]
at one point he's like you're gonna die
someday and i was like bro
i was like i didn't i'm not planning on
it dude
this is news to me
but you know it wasn't it wasn't bad
vibes or anything tony's tony's a total
sweetheart it was just kind of crazy
experience compounded by everything and
then what was even a little even kind of
crazy is that
later in the night the nelk boys showed
up and [ __ ] steak
i'm not even [ __ ] you the knuck boys
cruised in
wearing steak hoodies and with a 12 back
of happy dad seltzer like dude you these
guys do not stop
like no no shoddys or anything
but there was no conflict or anything
obviously but i i again i'm not trying
to say anything i respect everyone that
was there and you know god bless but it
was just super weird to see
them did they spot you oh yeah there was
not many people there oh okay no he
definitely i was getting side-eyed
okay it's a vibe right now from [ __ ]
kyle kyle was the one kyle i don't know
if he was trying again i don't know kyle
isn't really the one that ever uh
has like it's mostly
he will do it steve will do it and
bradley the gym you're right those two
guys are the ones that like seem to like
so the other guys weren't there
yeah
i mean we've definitely made fun of the
kyle guy but i've never seen him like
but they're all good buddies so i don't
know but kyle but he was there obviously
you know didn't nobody said anything but
it was just super weird i was like oh my
god bro with the steak hoodie and
everything i'm just spitting facts you
know
because i know those guys hate my guts
let's be real
well that's why i can't go republican
i swear to god everyone you can you're
guaranteed to meet someone that hates my
gods
yeah
true
but um
yeah you want to read those texts i was
sending you guys text i didn't know if
you wanted me to talk about it but yeah
you were a reader you were really high
and you were messaging us like oh my god
the boys are here
you can read it let me i gotta find them
but you know what i again i haven't also
said that you were on a bad trip
i didn't say that yeah you did they did
we said that we hope you're like it
would get better oh i said they're bad
they're doing bad vibes or something i
didn't say nothing but i didn't i wasn't
having a bad trip it's a vibe right now
i saw after i sent the message you guys
were all worried i was like i think i
conveyed the wrong thing
to them
yeah okay
uh
hold on i need to emphasize again i
haven't done anything like this in
decades like i don't do anything
you know i just this is just like a
weirdo
oh yeah also lena reminded me i
literally left my keys with the damn
valet
we were there for a long time by the way
so we drove we drove we were sober we
waited hours and hours and hours before
we drive
um but
ela has keys in her car
in her bag so we just walked to the car
and bailed
and then i was like oh [ __ ] i don't have
my keys but anyway go ahead okay so you
say the elk boys are here wearing steak
hoodies and then you say later bro i'm
ready to throw down
that's didn't you say dude i'm not gonna
lie
i had some crazy mushrooms and i'm high
as [ __ ] and they are bad vibes i was
just saying they're bad vibes they were
just making me feel like it was just a
bad vibe haven't seen the elks were bad
yeah yeah see i think we all interpreted
you saying the shrooms were bad vibes oh
no no no
it was the boys showing up got it okay
yeah
yeah i started
advising you to uh
yeah which environments
you know that's what you're setting
setting bro
but the anyway that you want to read
more is that it you just said the
gummies have nutritional influence i'm
like what the [ __ ] yeah it's crazy
but i'm gonna send it
the listening party was awesome
um super fun the new album is great by
the way
12
carat too thick
ladies and gentlemen
streaming now
he's back baby
so it was just a crazy crazy weird night
you know
for those reasons and i don't know it
definitely put me in a weird headspace
after the tony and then the kneel thing
and i was like what the [ __ ] but we had
a really good time we we eventually
hours and hours
uh
went back to austin's and hung out for a
little bit
so
it's been almost three years since his
last studio album well
right it was just coming out
like around the last time that he came
on the show i remember it was like a
about to drop
yeah yeah so there you go give it a
listen people really love love it i
thought it was amazing
the vibes were crazy there dude inside
the listening party they filmed it so i
don't know if where or when it's going
to show up somewhere
but um they were like blowing in a ton
of vapor
so
the whole floor like four feet up was
just
like a clock you couldn't see through it
and it was like red lights with the
mist and it just was so trippy in there
and then austin at one point was like
sitting on the floor right in front of
me like covered in smoke i don't know i
was like [ __ ] tripping balls dude
there was like a giant train i was on
the aisle and there was like a big ass
crane that was like come in and out to
get shots of austin and i was like i
mean it was so close to me i could
literally unplug
[ __ ] from it if i wanted to
uh
it was crazy it was fun but it was the
company was awesome
you know and that was a really fun night
so shout out to everyone who got me
who got me uh banned for a week i don't
think that that night would have been
possible without them so a really good
really happy coincidence there thank you
guys
thank you to all my haters shout out
who are [ __ ] and pissing and crying
right now by the way
oh you guys are so nice look peop you
guys already donated it that way on
yo
top
so nice yes
wait did i donate 2 000
oh it's first and top
hang on
yeah man you guys are so nice to the
sweetheart so there you go tony how did
uh
brittany react to uh
meeting post isn't she like oh it was
great everyone was on cloud nine i mean
everyone was just so happy there
and i was with oliver and brittany the
whole time you know it was just such a
fun night with those guys such good
good vibes good people there it was
really fun
was she invited uh on her own accord or
did you bring her no separately yeah no
it was weird like
britney and oliver both texted me
separately like are you going to this
post malone thing tonight i was like
yeah yeah dude
sick it was fun man
so anyway
that was basically um
that you know and then the next the next
day was uh
or no it wasn't the next day it was two
days later
was uh theodore's third birthday party
and we had all the kids over by the way
thank you to lena and abe you guys came
over and helped with with everything
turned out amazing thanks for having us
dude we had a um
we had a fire truck bouncy castle with a
slide
was such a hit
ahead yeah it was sick
you get on that
yeah yeah i jumped in it before everyone
came in theodore were theodore was a
little scared of it at first so i had to
uh kind of
show him what was up
but he loved it and there was a magician
that came by the way and these these are
three-year-olds it was i felt bad that
magician bond hard bro he bombed it was
a tough crowd man well because the kids
were they weren't paying attention to
him
and by the end of it there was literally
one kid watching
it was just a tough tough crowd man
it was a tough crowd for that poor
magician and the show was way too long
too man but shout out
alexander the great or something i think
his name yeah yeah
shout out though he put he the show was
great it was just
tough crowd man yeah
but it was really fun
but okay now that i've got all that out
of the way i think i touched on
everything here right
oh zach has a surprise
also during the break go ahead show your
wrist sack don't be shy
zach got the rolly i got the roller
i got the [ __ ] rule i mean a lot of
good things happened this week last week
thanks to our haters fantastic week
absolutely yeah tell me the story how'd
you get the rolling so last week the
week we were off um i go over to my
parents and there's a a box sitting for
me
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this i had
no idea
and um
open it up and it's a submariner
your dad bought it for you well he
bought and he's like you're going to
split this with me originally he's like
you're going to pay for this but then
he's like you're going to split this one
so you so he bought it it was in the box
it was in the box and then he and then
basically you get you paid him for half
of it right he's like that's great
that's really nice yeah now i'm happy
for you zach thank you and that was uh
and that was a nice gesture of your
dad's
i do have to say
getting someone a gift yeah and then
being like you have to pay for half you
owe me you owe me money but like i know
that you wanted it and so like obviously
you weren't gonna like reject that but
isn't that like a little weird to put
somebody in that position like hey i
bought this ten thousand dollar item
you're going to pay for half of it
honestly
i have no problem paying half i know you
don't i think i'm just saying that i'm
just saying like philosophically it's
hilarious oh my god it could pull
something like that well it was it was
very sweet of him and i i expected to
pay for half of it and i wanted to i
didn't you know i just feel like there's
something
more rewarding about that in some way
yeah you paid for you bought that thing
bro yeah so i got the [ __ ] rule you
got that status symbol now
so it's so is there a way to wear it so
people watch it like you can't wear long
sleeve shirts anymore i mean you know
you just roll up the sleeve a little bit
oh yeah yeah you guys show it yeah so
did you know have people been looking at
you have you noticed any one thing
popping up look no no
honestly the one it's not like gold or
anything like that it's super low-key
which is what i love about it i don't
know if i could wear
a gold watch or something like that
maybe when i'm a little older but um
it's just
it's a [ __ ] dream man
wow it really has been your dream for
years yes and i'm just glad i don't have
to buy it for you
that's awesome congrats dude thank you
very much thank you and it was course
ian's birthday young ian slater
do we love so well how old are you ian
28
done
so big one that's a big one
two eight two eight two eight
old man when i whenever i hear how old
i'm like that can't be right
i feel so old bro i know that feeling
breath it
crips blocker
it's crazy bro i know that feeling i'm
gonna be 20
37 i'm gonna be 37 this month
and like 36 i was comfortable but when
you get 37 you're just like a stone skip
away from 40. 40 is [ __ ] old as [ __ ]
dude
damn
when you get to the roundup years
for each decade it's like
yeah
you know it's 30. i'm basically 30.
this yeah i mean the stone starts
rolling downhill around like let's say
50
and just runs away with you
and then you're dead
yeah so good times very positive
i'm feeling good no i don't i don't mind
i don't mind getting old it's it's fine
you know it's nice it's fine it's good i
guess old man
now i still feel young i don't feel like
an old man young at heart
yeah
so congrats everybody you had a good
birthday ian yeah everyone everyone came
out and we went out uh
to this like arcade bar thing and we
love those barkhead yeah
yeah it was cool it was a lot of fun it
was cool best cake i've ever had really
that must have been sam must have been
behind that
i didn't make it i bought it somewhere
but it was the best cake i've ever had
it was really really really what kind of
cake was it a strawberry shortcake oh
[ __ ] i love that it was like unreal
next level where's my slice damn
when your birthday's coming up
yeah won't give me one of them it's
actually the same place that i got your
birthday cake last year that we had here
what did you get me with you like the
crying eyes the meme eyes oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah i'll get it again this year
yeah my birthday's coming up on the 25th
so
we'll have to plan something it's kind
of weird i have a friend a friend of
mine from back in the day
is having a wedding on my birthday and
it's like a destination wedding
so
that is weird it's a little odd but okay
that'd be fun
so okay let's talk about all the juicy
stuff now there's so much to go over
from this
band and so much
insane outrage you know
the thing is i don't understand why
people aren't more angry i love that
people are more angry at me than like
the fact that an 18 year old can buy two
ar15s on credit
it's not awesome he can just buy it on
credit he didn't have to pay for it you
don't have to worry about that
that's so insane people don't people are
more angry about my stupid ass joke that
resulted in uh let's think zero harm to
anyone
the 19 kids being
you know you know what happened to them
you know and since this is just some
stats to keep in mind as i go through
this outrage
there's been 30
mass s words 30
since the friday we got banned
how's that even possible how many days
is that i mean that was as of the last
night too so you know that that number
might have been up by uh
that included 146 people injured 31
killed
not a single week has gone by this year
without at least three mass s words
two hundred thirty two so we are
swirling this year i'm not i'm not even
gonna i don't wanna touch any of that
right now okay all right fair enough
232
this year so far
and then we're about halfway not even
halfway through the year
you know i was looking at this last year
was 700 that was a big that was a crazy
year 700 last year
keeps going up
so just keep that in mind as you see how
angry people are at me meanwhile
this is what's actually happening in the
world and they don't give a [ __ ]
the solutions people have to this
problem are literally insane i mean it's
like brazenly
it's brazenly
psycho it's just it's like spitting in
people's face who's buying this like
putting one door in
you know
i forget what state but they just made
it they just passed a law where teachers
can carry in school now what state was
that it was one of these
[ __ ] up states as you can imagine i
think it's ohio ohio
ohio too latinos carry guns after 24
hours of training
that's enough time
ohio
oh
nice drop i was about to say that drop
and then it just materialized now kids
who remember your high school experience
or kids are in high school now can you
imagine your teachers carrying
guns on them i mean that is just a that
is just a recipe
yeah for disaster
for so many reasons guys
it's nuts it's nuts but okay let's let's
go on to the cringe now
here i've got a album to start us off
with oh yeah this i gotta say and i and
i never i don't like to use this word
but this woman is such a [ __ ]
i mean this [ __ ] [ __ ] was going off
non-stop
and she i think this was like her big
15 minutes because she was going off
non-stop and she was digging up every
stupid [ __ ] thing about me she even
clipped there was one point she clipped
something about me
that was so stupid she erased it i think
it was from your ethan klein video
possibly she said what did he mean about
this and it was like
that's when you talked about having a
gun in your house i think no no it's
something even dumber than that
just for uh
some added context of who this is by the
way i don't know who she is actually but
this is great let's see
she's turning point usa well she was she
was actually fired after uh she was
hanging out with a bunch of open white
nationalists why do they care about that
well they have to keep up appearances
yeah so she she's an open i mean not
surprised she's an open white
supremacist who's angry about my dumb
joke like can you imagine like snowflake
alert like holy [ __ ] but yeah
um
she tweeted about me like a hundred
times hey
uh why did you call for the b word of
the nra meeting
why did you mock governor abbott's
disability and call for people to
physically harm him it's like dude shut
up man shut up [ __ ] i mean that's
basically right
i mean
to say i was calling for people to
physically harm him by saying someone
should put a stick in his spoke i'm
sorry but lady you are literally a
snowflake you are triggered cancel
culture snowflake you're everything you
say you hate
is so good
seems like a serious violation youtube
needs to do something about it you know
this this is what everyone was tweeting
i don't know if you yeah yeah she had so
many
kline on governor abbott clinton
encouraged more violence i hopes that
someone puts a stick in his effing
wheelchair and he tumbles out of his
seat do you really think that sounds bad
you hang out with hope with white
supremacists that participated in
january 6th do you really think that
sounds that bad
with peace and love you dumb [ __ ]
this is um of course what she imagined
oh this this is god
the next time it'll be an electric chair
holy [ __ ] dude
that's crazy though oh god that's
actually a crazy meme right there dude
holy [ __ ] though
yeah don't be mad at me god's the one
that dropped the tree on his ass
i never even seen the guy i never met
him once
you got to love how [ __ ] sensitive
these people are though right
like holy [ __ ] man
oh god that's good
what is this from the
what's this quartering pick uh he sent a
video of you and idubbbz shooting guns
yeah
and then she responded very insensitive
for a guy who claims to care so much
about chill but shooting a gun
i'm listening to it now
anyway
she goes on what did he mean by this oh
this is it this is the one i'm so glad
you guys caught this because she erased
it real fast she said we will
we will never move conservatives on this
issue
uh
dead children didn't move them with
sandy hook and it won't now it's become
a single issue i'm becoming a single
issuer voter anyone that takes money
from the nra's out anyone that doesn't
support gun reform is out she says what
did he mean by this i think she's trying
to
twist it into saying is out means that
i'm threatening them like
i mean lady
you're trying way too hard
what did he mean by this
just read it i mean it's pretty clear
what i'm not allowed to say i don't want
to vote for people now that's triggering
you
of course donald trump trump jr
even got in on the fun that was great
which is really a betrayal because as we
know he's a big supporter of leftovers
and friend of the show yeah i thought he
was a friend of the show
he upset me the most he launched our
inaugural episode right good luck with
all of that yeah
so he went against the family yeah
he said ethan klein has 2.3 or 2.9
million subscribers on youtube that's
the biggest disc of course yeah
soon to be free to get crushed
we'll be at 3 million any day now on our
way to
2.8 i'm like benjamin button of youtube
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ethan klein has 2.9 million subscribers
on youtube and has made multiple
encouragements for violence and death
against conservatives it's like [ __ ]
did you watch the video
i'm pretty sure that's not at all what
happened
you gotta love how they how they spin
that
and again this is just the conservo
sphere
disinfo propaganda machine doing its
work trying to change the conversation
everybody's spamming h 2.9 h 2.9
instead of h3h3
that's good oh h 2.9
guys that's not funny
that's not funny age 2.9 get the frick
out of here with that
[Laughter]
oh i by the way i responded to him you
want to pull that one up yeah
he didn't take the bait unfortunately
tough guy he tagged me though you see
this [ __ ] i was like okay he wants to
[ __ ] go he tagged me i was like okay
[ __ ] let's go
but i tweeted at him and he didn't
respond
i think luckily for me this this whole
story never got to fox news
um
which is when it got like with hassan's
thing when he got into this whole
similar situation i think his escalated
even further because it went to fox news
tucker or some [ __ ] i was like i was
afraid once tucker talks about it then i
think i would be truly
truly [ __ ]
or just in a heart a really harder place
yeah i thought that was coming
yeah i did too i really did i mean
mate yeah this is maybe giving them too
much credit but maybe they watched it
and just
thought this wasn't something to go off
of
but i mean they go off at anything so
but even so even alex jones when he
talked about it he
he couldn't even do like a whole he
couldn't even muster a real scream
exactly he talked about it wasn't even
red in the face yeah
hey donald trump jr remember when your
dad inspired an insurrection that killed
six people so it's like yeah i mean dude
are you really one to talk here didn't
you give a speech on january
6 talking about
stormed the capital or i don't know what
you said but you said some dumb [ __ ] so
how about you [ __ ] uh
you look in the mirror there okay
okay
thanks
back to ashley my fave
hey
oh this is exactly we already saw this
one
uh jack and then these are all the you
know the best right
oh yeah i think i was just showing that
he got trump got it from her
elijah schaefer who's also like uh
is any also one of these like
fringe
right i recognize the name that one
doesn't google it i think he's part of
some really terrible elijah schaefer so
this one also went viral this club he
says ethan clan of h3 podcast calls for
violence and provoking the public to b
word the nra conference it's like [ __ ]
no
you're so pathetic oh my goodness
gracious
what's this
what's still
what's though a stick
uh it means to
uh
incite people with your words to uh okay
do something
uh violent
um i'm glad he was able to take a break
from his meltdown about a pizza hut
about that did you see that yes i did
it's been going on for weeks
yeah did you find out who elijah
schaefer is
i'm looking into it
elijah schaefer let's see he is
frequently misunderstood often taken out
of context almost funny host and
reporter for blaze tv blaze tv is um
the the guy
the [ __ ] is that guy named glenn beck i
could barely remember his name it's
another one of those propaganda [ __ ]
psycho publication by the way rita's
read his description again
uh frequently misunderstood often taken
out of context
often taken out of context okay baby
interesting kind of ironic why is this
his [ __ ] twitter profile picture like
why
what are you doing with your mouth you
could have picked like any frame
like why you gotta pick like an
awkwardness
i try to think but nothing happens
you're trying to think but nothing
happens who the [ __ ] is this guy kyle
kasuf
flagging for the fbi i love this they
start tagging the fbi snitch bro are you
serious
you're seriously tagging the fbi dude
i mean you looks it's so embarrassing
for you guys wait who is this guy
because i've seen him
uh conservative
activists survived 2018
stoneman high school shooting this oh he
survived one of those yeah
oh gun rights yes yes yes
okay
interesting that some went right someone
left
as a result of that
[Music]
nonetheless he's calling the fbi guys
let's get him out here
of course cernovich who you know gorilla
brain this guy is mentally ill
um like psychiatrically like clinically
insane
hello team youtube why do you allow this
on your platform
thank you cernovich
it was just a whole lot of this stuff
i made a whole album for the quartering
in keemstar oh the quartering and
keemstar get their whole they get their
own albums yeah
there's of course alex jones did me the
honor now i've been talked about m4s
before
one of one of his uh employees who
actually got arrested
for january 6th made a whole segment
about me previously i posted a picture
of theodore when he was like just born
he was naked and i was holding him and
you could see his butt and he called me
he said i'm a
p word yes the guy is so you know but
but now the man himself has acknowledged
me
so this is pretty dope that set is
insane by the way
the [ __ ] calls for violence
by bette midler
and by other democrats and other
operatives like the h3 podcast ethan
klein you're not offering 4 million
viewers a day
and the issue is if i talked like this
i would get arrested for inciting
violence and for calling for organized
violence and and i should be by the way
this is this is the angle they always
take they're like we're not we're not
snowflakes we're not for council culture
we just do this because that's what
would happen to me and the world's
unfair it's like [ __ ] you're doing it
um i'm pretty sure you've said worse
stuff than that on a daily basis alex
jones
conspiracy theorist alex jones accused
of inciting violence after saying biden
will be removed one way or the other and
i mean this is literally just the first
google result you could probably find
yeah
like a hundred thousand examples of
alex jones he's like i should go to jail
for saying that [ __ ]
it's like okay buddy
okay he looks like he's in like a like a
magic the gathering booster box dude
totally all of the art
is that what's going on here
maybe it is the viewers holding the
apocalypse
yeah i was impressed with his overhead
cameras too anytime once it shows
documents there's cameras wait but one
thing that always cracks me up about
alex jones is the dude
he when he's talking about stuff he has
printouts yeah he prints documents
and physically the document's right here
because it's like such a high-tech
studio and this [ __ ] guy
literally prints [ __ ]
instead of using a computer watch this
for organized violence and and i should
be you have free speech
but when you say we need to go bomb the
nra
i didn't say that they said that no you
said it you said it you said i left
calling for violence
ethan klein
of the h3 podcast
calls for violence and provoking the
public to bomb the nra conference in
houston this isn't yelling fire in a
theater
this is specifically saying somebody
needs to bomb what is he fire fire in
the theater is illegal no it's not
that's like a theater
oh it's not yeah oh okay i mean people
say that all the time you're responsible
to do that i mean it's irresponsible and
they'll probably kick you out but it's
not you won't get arrested for doing
that
and then mentally ill people
can and could talking about what
mentally ill people do when you're the
one that literally has harassed sandy
hook parents for years forced them to
move
while they're grieving for the tragic
loss of their child to be called fake
actors like how dare you accuse anyone
of anything you vile [ __ ]
creep dude i hope you get taken for
everything i mean he is so vile i don't
i don't understand people who are like
are like oh he's so fun he's so i love
alex jones he's such a character no the
man is a vile
piece of [ __ ]
sucking a ding-dong
he's not cute it's like actually
horrific the [ __ ] he says pretext to
then attack the first amendment the free
speech exercise of the nra the governor
of texas canceled lee greenwood
cancelled disgusting cowardice
senator cruz and trump so he's making it
sound like greg abbott didn't go to the
nra because of my my b word threat i
think he didn't go because it's bad
optics bro
good and defended the second amendment
here is ethan
what a loving liberal you guys he's not
just for censoring all his competition
or people you guys know the clip he just
said someone should be where that
building but he cuts it right after you
say that he doesn't include the part of
you taking it back
gotta love it
and right afterwards i'm like
oh we gotta roll that back and i started
laughing
um this is the oh this is the actual
photo on his desk cam
yeah dude that's nuts what is i love it
it's uh four horsemen of the apocalypse
so what he's down he's like pro four
horseman i don't know which is a cool
cool painting maybe just didn't
ask the you just thought it was sick it
is cool but he's a member of the pack
isn't that some end time [ __ ]
yes
yeah
i disagree with him he supports banning
us off the internet no now he wants
people to bomb things
but it's mostly peaceful right
yes so there you go alex jones
and of course the the benefit
is that we have now alex jones drops
right zap here is ethan klein so there
you go h3 podcast
beautiful what a loving liberal thank
you alex i am i feel that i am loving
um
tim paul the usual suspect you know
tim paul was going after me i got into
it with him
on twitter
no amount of children dying this was my
favorite takeaway
temple is a
big brain he's a well-respected thinker
in conservative circles and so his take
on all this you know
in the wake of this tragedy is this
no amount of children dying
should justify someone having their
rights take taken away that's just it
you do not get to strip someone of their
human rights
because of harm to children by the way i
love the idea that owning an ar-15 is a
human right
the
unalienable uh every man was born with
the unalienable right to freedom
pursuit of happiness
and the uh
owning of mass weapons of mass
destruction and carnage hell yeah
this is what's always gets me too with
you know them
pearl clutching about all of this it's
like
these guys all the time
when they're talking about gun rights
and you know gun reform
restrictions anything like that
tim poole in particular
they always
have either the implicit or oftentimes
explicit threat that if you try and take
my guns
i'm going to kill you i'm going to start
a civil war absolutely like there the
threat of violence is not
just under the surface it's it's on the
surface it's being explicitly cited as
this will be what happens if you try
and pass a law restricting you know my
perceived right to own this item
that's a really good point yeah these
guys talk about violence all the time
and actual threats like real threats i
mean the nra for god's sake one of their
big
moments or big sayings is from my cold
dead hands you know you'll have to pry
it from my cold dead hands charles
yeah charlton heston yeah
do you wanna you wanna have a
conversation about trans kids
dude how do you segue
from gun control to trans kids only tim
not only him they all do it now like
they've just realized that you know
that's where the i'm really sorry
it's like trans people have it hard
enough
and right now they're just they found
themselves in the crosshair of this
horrible culture war of conservatives
where they are just yeah they're they've
just come in they're just the
culture war item of the moment and i'm
so sorry
to uh
to my trans brothers and sisters and
or everything in between i don't know
whatever gender or not
but
um
it really sucks it's really sad
i mean being transphobic is practically
a way of life for conservatives at this
point it's like second nature to them
and the harm that will befall them by
them being sterilized by puberty
blockers
by them um being being castrated or by
girls getting top surgery you want to
talk about their their rights or
infringement no i was talking about gun
control
interesting segway though dude anyway
i've seen enough tim paul it's such a
dumb ass weirdo you know what you know
the problem is though he's it's
definitely not me
i hate that people think tim paul is
smart
that that's just
maybe that's just uh signifying the
caliber of thinkers on the right i don't
know the benchmark is very low these
people are all very very dumb i think
and i'm sorry to say that
no definitely
definitely
very dumb
his
we haven't looked at it yet but his his
tweet we were talking about before the
show his response is that in the dock
yeah okay good it was just baffling to
me well if you guys think that was a
crazy take wait till you hear this steve
the second amendment protects your right
to own nuclear weapons i believe an
individual citizen
in this country has a right to own a
nuclear warhead but not a delivery
device oh all of it all of
absolutely all of it
all of it
dude the second amendment
nuts dude
this can't be what
how are you going to control ars when
this dude thinks
that you can own a nuke yeah i'm running
my own manhattan project in my basement
not a big deal just enriching some
uranium in my in my suburban home right
well
ethan
you didn't
you didn't do him the courtesy of
including the full context of his
comments which he was very kind to
provide in his reply oh yeah we started
arguing now he goes
i appreciate that ethan did not extend
to me the same courtesy he demands of
the right
he cut out where i said and most people
think that's wrong and we would need to
amend the constitution
private tears were legal when it was
written
and they could flatten coastal cities
now privateers was like
ships it was such a stupid weird thing
to say okay
uh and i responded i said first of all
you're right these are totally the same
thing privateers and of course you know
a nuclear explosion but what's really
funny about his response is he goes
he goes most people think that owning a
nuke is wrong it's like [ __ ] what the
what do you think right how am i taking
you out of context at all it literally
change does not change it doesn't change
the meaning of what he said at all
adding that sentence not at all
not at all
so again he really thanks for providing
that though he really is a dumb dumb
dumb he's a dumb guy yeah he's not smart
he's actually just not smart
um dumb
now we move on to the to my faves of
course keemstar was he saw this as his
golden chance to get me permanently
banned
uh keemstar went all out baby and the
title of his drama alert was just golden
he made a drama alert titled ethan klein
calls for bombing u.s citizens based on
political difference like what the [ __ ]
did
also it's hashtag dramaalert logan paul
hashtag oh
all right so let's look at all of his
tweets
logan's like why you gotta associate me
with that man
[Laughter]
i'm gonna need a soda for this
part um
you guys are gonna have to strap in for
these man these get really crazy
keemstar
uh why was leafy
banned for bullying
but ethan klein calls for a terrorist
attack on u.s soil
i love the u.s soil thing like
he's like well if you call for a
terrorist attack in like afghanistan
then i get it
and only gets a youtube strike something
is not right
what did you want i got a strike
i mean why do you why you got to compare
me to leafy the dude made like 20 videos
about one person
and probably had a bun i don't care
about leafy whatever
um
ethan klein calls for terrorist attacks
on u.s oil youtube has yet to respond
you got to love how he gets on this i
just it's so awesome i just want to say
i included that twice on top because he
retweeted all these tweets multiple
times throughout the
that's awesome
god he's really crying [ __ ] and
pissing right now i had a really nice
vacation game
thank you bro i should thank you
actually
is this video worth watching do we have
it it's under
alright let's watch this enlightened
take by keemstar
on youtube there is a terms of service
there's rules if you break the rules you
get in trouble you get a strike whatever
right you know you get punished all
right
every youtuber has to follow these rules
except for can you turn it up a little
bit for me
yeah one sec
uh go ahead
follow these rules
except for
ethan klein we have seed i just got a
strike i think he recorded this before
we got the strike and i got a strike
last time i talked about him
right that's true like
right that's a good point i i i hate to
say it
we literally got a strike for bullying
keemstar so
i hate to say it but again i do think
this is anti-semitic trope because they
always show this picture of me and susan
together i met her once years ago i'll
be honest youtube doesn't [ __ ] talk
to me anymore i've been writing my guy i
write him emails i call him i text him
like i can't get an answer about
anything okay they didn't even give me a
heads up this time about the strike this
idea that i have some deep
backroom connections is it's like george
soros [ __ ]
and of course the ceo susan is is jewish
i really feel like it has a tinge of
anti-semitism it really does
throughout the years this dude breaking
terms of service non-stop and not be
punished by youtube well here's my
second strike
he calls for a bomb threat listen to
this okay i'll roll
nice that's nice
yeah you'll roll it back but you just
said it you just said it yeah you'll
roll it back but you just said it
you just said it any other youtuber
that called for a [ __ ] terrorist
attack on u.s soil would be permanently
banned yeah but that's not really what
happened is it
i didn't come out and like uh
i didn't like present a plan of action i
mean by that logic then he really meant
death to all
j words yeah well that's [ __ ] up
that's actually more [ __ ] up than what
i said if you take it literally as
possible death to all jews yeah what did
you mean by that keemstar
so i hate the jews
yeah i think it's pretty obvious
keemstar hates the jews would
on youtube there is a terms of service
there's rules if you break the rules you
get in trouble that's right whatever
right you know you get punished all
right oh it's so long
so that's it or is there more that's it
there you have it
i don't know what you want dude i got a
strike [ __ ]
you want this keemstar [ __ ]
bro i don't know how to tell you this
but i really don't
frustrating
um
so
anyway
it goes on
curious talking about me on dramaalert
for our very first story ethan klein
from the h3h3 podcast bro i love they
use that that photo is awesome i mean
that photo's hilarious
they keep using it they think it's like
a dunk you know i took that photo of
myself right
okay
all right what's up there are rules what
is that sounds like that hold on one
second
i'll be right back okay
what's that there's someone at the front
door
i don't know what you heard something
banging downstairs
hold on what's that guys
damn what is it
yeah
yes
can you come with me
what's this about you have to do this
right now we're gonna yeah i'm sorry
excuse me we need to talk to you about
some of the comments that you've been
making
okay well i'm doing i'm actually live
right now
let's go who are you can you identify
yourself uh yes i'm with the federal
block building investigator i've
received multiple reddit accounts what
multiple reddit reports fbi
and daniel keem yes fbi
all right i guess guys give me a sec
thank you hold on what's that guys i'll
be right back oh
uh
all right mr glenn so
to start off in the last episode you
said something about
let's bomb it with emotional protest in
minecraft do you realize what this has
caused
so
uh
this is just a picture of a minecraft
explosion what's that gotta do with me
this is the national redstone
association it was attacked by griefers
this weekend do you have any idea how
much diamond or it's going to cost the
taxpayers
the national
redstone listen i i don't even play
minecraft i don't know anything about
minecraft that's just like a joke people
say they say in minecraft i i didn't
have i don't have anything just not
happy with you
do you know that
i don't know anything about mojing i
just i i swear to god listen this is
just a huge misunderstanding i don't i
just was kidding you say in minecraft i
just please deal with this one please
i don't think you understand the gravity
of this situation i want you to take a
look at this
do you see that
that's multiple minecraft steve's in the
infirmary all of our revive beds have
been filled up do you know what kind of
headache this card for us these are
minecraft characters in a hospital bed
yes look at their their own life support
listen i i didn't i didn't listen i was
i had nothing to do with this okay i
don't know any grievers i'm sorry that
these are not hurt how about these guys
are they your pals do you know them
do you work with them they're a
terrorist organization these are
creating coordinated attacks on servers
around the globe these are these are
creepers these are just a minecraft
creeper yeah top of our list in the fbi
you seem confused i don't know these
creepers i'm telling you like i know i i
just i can't deal with this can i can i
be honest with you right now before you
say anything else i think you need to
talk to your lawyer
okay do you have one i need to get a
hold of um
we need our boy panda
pnp
god i need pmp i need to you know pnp
let's go
he can sort this out for me where are
you talking about pnp from let's go
david yes yes guys we'll get him on the
phone please
you know what i'm online don't worry
about it no no it's all right um no get
him on the phone guys no no please don't
do that please please don't do that uh
we don't want any smoke with that guy uh
why don't we just
let you off with a warning
and then thank you don't do it again
thank you so much i'm so sorry i swear
to god i'll never do it again i have not
i don't know i'm so sorry for the damage
think about the victims next time i i
will the national redstone association
the nra is what it stands for in
minecraft i'll never mess with them
again i'm so sorry this is just a huge
misunderstanding good all right thank
you i'm so so sorry get out of here
okay thank you just get out of my face
that was scary dude did you guys see
that everything okay
i'm like shaking right now
oh my god that was so scary it's gonna
happen
he let me off when he heard the pnp
let's go oh let's let's oh
the national red block association of
minecraft
the nra in minecraft you guys
justice prevails
all those pixels in the hospital oh my
god i'm so scared right now i was my
heart is pumping i was wild dude
holy [ __ ]
all right
let's go shout out to the uh to the fbi
for letting me off life
shout out we love the fbi here don't we
folks
all right where were we
keem dramaalert
it's on youtube there are terms of
service all right you break the rules
you get in trouble but this guy can do
and say anything he wants with no
consequences again it's just so
preposterous it's provably wrong
yeah you know i was
i really was giving him the benefit of
the doubt that this video was made
before the punishment came down
um not that it's a valid argument anyway
but
you're totally right i totally forgot
the last time we got a strike was
literally because of him yeah what the
[ __ ] are you talking about months ago
exactly that's what i'm saying it's like
an anti-semitic i really truly believe
it is and i mean it's not a far cry this
guy literally told his fans to tweet at
me death to all jews so i mean like is
it really that much of a far cry just
accused him of being an anti-semite
anti-semite
this example is him calling for a
terrorist
attack what'd you say play that again
terrorist
terrorist terrorist terrorists
are that terrorist
terrorist terrorist paris oh like a
terrorist balcony balcony yeah a little
bit of a george bush situation there a
terrorist terrorist terrorist
terrorist terrorist dude what the [ __ ]
it's little romeo and juliet romeo julia
wow
that long pause after the statement and
he had to wait until somebody working on
his podcast called him out to roll it
back he'd have to wait a while
definition that would be a terrorist
hold on hold on he's defining terrorism
for us
what are we doing here wait a person who
he's he's saying i'm a terrorist that's
amazing terrorists calling for a
terrorist attack now the clip you just
witnessed that happened last night many
reporters are asking youtube for a
statement youtube has yet to respond
reporters she's means people who work
for like breitbart
and trump jr
these are report reporters in keemstar's
world
awesome right guys incredible stuff
terrorist
terrorist
ah so good it's just so good
you had to wait until your employees
corrected you it was literally
i think we all at the same time were
like let's roll that back dan was the
first to speak
and i think we all were just like okay
wendy when we were on time yeah it's
rewind time uh
um
this is probably my favorite video that
came out of it was this guy
legally armed
who [ __ ] caught uh here just give me
the youtube link i want actually i want
to read the comments the comments were
gold on this one man it's right under it
okay thank you
yes so this guy
is such a such a such a good american
man
i love like how [ __ ] hyped that intro
is and it cuts to this [ __ ]
horrible shot of this from like under
his chin for some reason
probably because it's his laptop like
blown out
it's his laptop webcam bro
my guess is but you got to turn the r i
can't hear him
or chosen the um emergency
um
information you know emergency complaint
by the way it's such an emergency such a
credible threat he's calling the
non-emergency line
we're a lot quicker so
in their defense
i chose
non-emergency mainly because i did not
want to tie up and get in the way of any
other potential emergencies that were
happening right now since this wait i
thought this was incredible
uh death threat against all the people
in the nra a couple days ago and of
course the convention is over now i'm
just now finding out how to get through
there so that's why i wanted you guys to
see this
dude this guy's a literal karen he's a
gun owning caring you guys
this is what these conservatives are
actually like the cry about snowflakes
and cancel culture this is this is who
you are man
this is who you are
i watch texas i can help you uh yes
ma'am um i just returned from the
nra annual meeting in houston texas at
the george r brown convention center
and uh while i was in there there was a
person online his name is ethan klein
uh-oh he was on a podcast and he made
the comment that someone should bomb
that building and later said let's kill
everyone in that effing building and i'd
like to file a
actual complaint against this person
i was one of the people
his name is ethan klein
by the way these people have not reached
out to me yet so
huh
apparently they did not uh find the
threat to be so credible
what do you mean
i'm sorry k-l-e-i-n
and his podcast is i think h3 podcast or
vh3 podcast
um and those were the
um
you know that's where i pulled the video
down from but i don't you know i don't
really know i didn't really i don't know
nothing about this nobody
i do know he's a jew
does that matter
i think that's where he publishes
by the way all these people we were
showing were tweeting out pictures of me
and susan too and that was their
their great moment
i think he's just on a regular podcast i
guess you could get that on spotify or
wherever i again i don't follow the guy
just
was told about this shout out
you can listen on spotify you can listen
on youtube it's on all the rss feeds
yeah leave a review if you want leave a
review 12 in the world guys thanks for
listening 12 in the united
states um yeah leave a review thank you
for the plug dude appreciate that
while i was there and i feel like you
know there were signs that the uvalde
killer had made some some statements
online and those weren't followed up on
i just feel like these things have to be
followed up on absolutely yeah that's
what our department is for i'm the uval
i'm the uvaldi killer
100
can i say something real quick yes just
to the guy's benefit excellent audio
oh good audio fantastic okay we like
that fantastic audio fresh and fit could
never we like that no that's you've got
to give credit where credit's due the
man has good audio yes
and uh you um
do you remember what the specific video
was i can see it
i can see well i think it's been taken
down by youtube now uh thankfully but i
can send you the video clip i have a
video clip on my phone of it i can email
it to you
i can include an attachment to an email
send it right over to you i'll tell you
what man i got this attachment right
here
i'm going to zip it
on over to you i got to do a zip file
ma'am do you know how to unzip this
thing i can't open it you have airdrop
on
man i can ma'am i can send a disc to you
you give me your address
you could um go on our website
um it's
iwatchtx.com let me make sure it's
called that one
um and it'll give you the option to
basically submit all the information and
add attachments that way we can get the
attachments directly but we'll go ahead
and start working on this email okay is
there a way you guys can communicate
back to me after you've done whatever
you do
um just go ahead and put your um
information um
i want to know when you all arrested
could you give me some kind of
confirmation that you've gone ahead and
used the tactical squad to ambush and do
a forceful entry into ethan klein's
residence i want you to shoot and kill
his whole family i want you to engage
ethan climb with kinetic precision he
talks about it later how it's a credible
threat is she because she's like is this
serious he's like oh very serious
can you uh can you update me was he a
jew can you update me on this on his
status there it's almost like a richard
christie phone
yeah yeah
hey
can you check on him yeah reporting
party
um like portion of the report and then
um
once they get sent out to the region uh
it would be harris county they would be
the ones to follow up not us okay it's
harris county um
sheriff's department
dps dps okay and you're with uh dhs
no we're with dps no we're with these
nuts
got em
[ __ ] wrecked
the counter-terrorism department of dps
i followed
counter-terrorism i was online trying to
get through dhs and got you guys so i
didn't know who i ended up winning bhl
shipping instead yeah honestly this is
pretty much exactly what our department
obsesses we process like online breadth
and there's a moment here i want you
guys to see coming up if you were to
have said it to you directly then you
could obviously immediately report it to
police but also reported to us so you
contacted the right people okay well i
sure appreciate it and again hopefully
you guys are successful in getting this
taken care of apprehending this wanted
criminal antares we i hope you all
successful and
breaching his home and do do you all any
all the police need any help i have some
firearm training and i'd love to join
y'all i would love to volunteer my
services
just uh just a heads up they got some
arabs there too there's a there is a
known air
there's two arabs in that one
area yeah darn garnet you got you may
want a swat team before you go in there
now
they are armed and dangerous
like again that website was iwatchtx.org
and it'll give you live
box of chocolates
and we'll get that as soon as you submit
it perfect i just uh wrote that down and
i'm gonna go uh make that uh follow that
uh statement right now
okay yeah he's filling it out and a
partner says do you think these are
credible
and he's like these are very credible
very urgent
you never know what you're going to get
he called me unclean look he called me
fat he called me fast description of
your shirt yeah
assumption that he's white um i i think
he may be so again not that that matters
where it says at the very end uh
comments clothing distinguishing
features i put unclean looking tie dyed
t-shirt again this is a judgment card
do you think do you think i'm still
wearing that shirt
it's just like
it's an unclean tie-dye shirt
it's unclean it's unclean look what
hopefully he has not cleaned the shirt
in the time from the pitch my episode
aaron to now hold on [ __ ] my shirt is
clean okay so back the [ __ ] off that was
a that was a fresh crosstalk that i saw
um and just i think that's the most
accurate description that i could make
based on what the uh mr klein is wearing
in his video do you not feel stupid at
this point like there's got to be a
point in this process where he feels
like this is the so dumb but no he
doesn't know when he goes on patriotic
duty the activity how suspicious was the
activity i chose holly suspicious there
were he how suspicious on a scale of one
to ten it was a tan that's all i
i feel like this was highly suspicious i
do think this is a credible threat by
this person holy spirit was the person
or person's attempt to conceal their
behavior i said no i didn't think they
were
so then i put the
length of the or the detail of the so
then i put the detail of the complaint
ethan klein of the h3 podcast made death
threats against myself and tens of
thousands of
people in the convention center in
houston texas there for the nra annual
meeting his exact comments included
someone should bomb that building and
let's kill everyone in that effing
building bro i did not say that did i
let's kill everyone in that building
i don't know i built
[Applause]
[Music]
bro that's a period there you can't even
put a period there it's not even a false
the full sentence again i don't follow
the guy
yeah
yeah exactly maybe you should
look into this a little bit before you
report me to the terrorist
police the dhs the nra the nhs the uh he
look i i reported him to ice he may be
looking a little foreign
no he kind of looks white to me but he's
got it
he's white but he got a drop of
something we got caught up nice about
that that can be real insidious they
look just like us
i tuck you up man
sometimes i sneak on through
i mean that eight rep don't even look
arrow
[Laughter]
i love the idea of like agents looking
into this and seeing on the same episode
we have a mountain dew taste test in a
disco ball bathroom review
you know it's such a shame that episode
got taken down because it was a great
episode it was olivia's comeback episode
with the bathroom although we're gonna
are we gonna try to re-upload it dan
we edited out the yeah we
can try uh
i don't want to get busted though yeah
suck
cam did you already start shopping i
should yeah i i dropped it in the
whatsapp over the week but i can send
you it again
you know i should
my guy just doesn't answer me but i'm
gonna try to get an answer about
if we cut it all out and upload it
because if we remove everything just
even remotely talking like just leave
the goof and gaff segment section no
talk about any of this stuff like that
that's got to be fine right i just want
to make sure because i don't have to
take i'll have to take a second pass
because i just cut out the jokes that
got us
the first time i mean if we want to be
extra careful maybe just cutting like
everything i don't want any remotely
touching it i don't want a second strike
obviously you know i don't want to point
fingers but i think olivia may be bad
luck
what wait i've been thinking about that
wait why are you bad luck because the
first time she was on the show we got
banned for that right that was the one
where you pretended to be his girlfriend
yeah we also made a joke because i came
back so literally last friday before we
started the show we were like we got to
be careful like last time you you came
back
i don't think you're bad luck
well i think you just
i think you being around gets me all
hyped up and i do dumb [ __ ] you know
what i mean it's good obsessed it is
charged up
so it is my fault but in the best way
[ __ ] crazy when you're around me dude
it's not your fault we messed it up
yeah no we messed it up not your fault
it's not your following
yeah um
this guy's great any folks
love him
the more recent rampage killings of
innocent people have been preceded by
online thresh [ __ ] nobody asks for a
[ __ ] editorial
he goes into explaining why he's
reporting me
just tell him what happened less violent
than mr klein's and the killers went on
to commit their horrible acts after
their threat they didn't ask for an
essay dude
or were ignored this isn't the sap
actions and comments are unacceptable
reckless and dangerous i felt like this
karen just wants to complain somewhere
that's all this is you see what this is
he's literally just complaining to the
manager right now
they didn't ask for your opinion bro
they said who what when where
i think that these liberals are really
going too far they can't hear me because
they're listening to kids bob i had kid
bop on 10 and i couldn't hear him at
first
all joking aside this was a good
representation of this person's threats
and the incredible nature of what i
think they are and why i think they
shouldn't be ignored because i do think
they are credible especially knowing
that he has such a large following
and
it's a very good chance that some of his
followers were very very unchanged he's
already back from the nra unhurt
without incident
and i do feel like even though the
convention is over
he has set the precedent out there for
how he feels about how people like me
and other innocent americans should be
treated just because we are second
amendment rights followers and
supporters so then i could upload my
attachment anyway that's about that's
basically it there are some really great
comments though
of course he he he
sticked the sweaty unkempt h3o beast
masses have made it to the comments
section here you will see they are just
as powerless in the comments as they are
in the real world first of all are they
powerless or they dangerous terrorists
that are about to commit a terrorist act
exactly hold on
that's so weird he pinned it he can't
make a bit it's weird that he pinned
that that they
that they're absolutely powerless to
actually do anything i want to stand up
for our fans a little bit the only
sweaty unkept obese mess is me the fans
are all beautiful and all you guys in
the studio are beautiful fit legends
what a loving liberal
don't talk about my boss like that thank
you girl yeah girl
this guy acts like the adult version of
the kid that would run around naruto's
story in style in middle school and have
to take his classes in outdoor bungalows
apart from the normal kids
oddly specific
yeah that guy
that is definitely that kid who wrote
that comment yeah i
wish they would put this kind of energy
into saving kids i mean that's the truth
watching this from outside of america is
genuinely like a fever dream how is that
country real that i wonder myself
this guy really thinks he's doing
something
uh
yeah oh my god i can't wait for ethan to
react to this yeah here you go
so
i don't know pretty amazing there are
actual real problems happening in our
country ethan klein is pretty much the
least of our concern wait wait wait the
the comment that he hearted watching
ethan have a hissy fit over this is
golden dude you just published a video
of you you of you calling the cops over
a podcast
for like also this was five days ago i
haven't even watched it until right now
he's a huge drama queen yeah you are
literally
you're you are a
you are literally a drama queen this is
like the real housewives of nra uh
second amendment losers
he threatened to kill me
the real house husbands of alabama
i tell you that man made death threats
against me personally and everyone in
there not clickbait
this is our favorite new t-channel
actually i really love the armed america
i would love to hear commentary about
like jeffree star and stuff by this guy
oh man that would be good you see bro i
think you actually have a future i
really do think you have a future in tea
somebody in the uh chat said yo you
missed one of my favorite parts uh
the idiot said on multiple occasions how
hard it was to get through the captcha
uh oh [ __ ] he
couldn't figure out how to get past the
bot
uh i mean this comment just says that he
says that at one point so we watched the
whole damn thing but i do remember
seeing that maybe it's at the very
beginning
oh wait let's find the capture moment
it's gotta be right at the top right
when he gets on the website
bro why did you include you failing at
captcha somewhat simple you go to the
website as i mentioned earlier i wanted
to make sure that i was not clogging up
any emergency personnel for any you know
timely emergencies that were happening
at that very moment so where it asked me
the type of incident uh even though it's
school related because the school was
what initiated his comments are you dumb
it's such a stretch i understand what
they're saying they want to know
is this person going to shoot up at a
school
he goes well i don't know it is related
to 8 40 is the time bro you are the
dumbest [ __ ] person man
something about sniffing that that gun
powder all day slows your brain cell
count
for all the information that i had and
read it back to me and then it had to
capture which was almost as challenging
as trying to identify
uh how much i don't think so good mr
klein wade and what he was gave me a
reference number
the capture was almost as hard as
guessing how much i weigh
by the
like i can do this here's one here's one
here's one here's one that's it
you're literally dumber than a spambot
oh shout out to whoever pointed that out
in the chat because that's amazing
i'll tell you these captions get me
every time
i can't i can't use any websites
can't get past the camera oh foiled
again
he's gonna call the cops on google next
for the caption these captions
i've been
terrorized in my home by google
i'm gonna define terrorism someone who
terrorizes me in my home
[Music]
y'all seen these captions but these
captures be ruined america
these bots are ruined in america boy
i try to go online and buy myself
a rifle and i can't get through because
of the captures and that was my right
[Music]
seems like the type of guy
say what he seems like the type of guy
to say the google instead of google i
went on the google google yeah i went
off the google i couldn't get no website
pass them damn captures the goddamn big
one from arizona
and told me to identify all the gators
in arizona that
google is like practicing their ai based
on those single-handingly like [ __ ]
up their ai recognitions
[Music]
i was on their website buying some
propane and i can't get no propane to
capture it
how am i supposed to eat without my
propane man you won't get a flying cow
man you're gonna load up them dynamite
and old cannon like that dick with a
boom man they'll absolutely fly it all
over
yeah come on now stewie
well shout out to legally armed america
and i don't know if someone that dumb
should be legally armed and that's my
best argument against the second
amendment mm-hmm well said
but fantastic audio oh great audio
fantastic audio
legally on my camera dumb as hell you
work on that camera angle just just a
just a tad
well moving on to my
maybe the most unhinged of everyone the
quartering was really losing his mind i
think that that segment we did where we
caught where we said listen you're going
to say my clothing line is for p words i
mean you know whoever smelted dealt it i
think is what we decided was the most
apt
you know comparison for him
and i think that whole segment really
twisted him wrong because
he went on an absolute war path to check
out the quartering
the man who shits and pisses in a drain
hole in his basement uh oh holy [ __ ] h3
productions this can't be real
oh baby
seriously at a straight rush this is
career ending [ __ ]
you need to delete this before the
secret service rolls up jesus dude you
have a family
just uh in the drain
[Music]
i mean i mean to be fair we did delete
it
yeah we did immediately but at the same
time i mean
i'd be more worried about pissing and
[ __ ] in a
basement drain with a headache only
i gotta correct the record for my man
jeremy here
okay
he only pisses on the floor he doesn't
[ __ ] uh no i have oh
am i wrong about that i don't know that
we can
say definitively that he doesn't
i'm [ __ ] my basement yeah
there you have it as if ethan would put
it i apologize i retract what i just
said yeah i roll that back he won one
time he waffle stomps in it he did [ __ ]
on the floor in a wall she hit the floor
on a walmart but not the basement not in
his own basement
you're making assumptions yeah i'm just
saying he's capable of doing it oh he's
certainly capable so yeah
where is the best place to [ __ ]
give him enough
bud light
by the way this tweet really ruffled
deaders feathers i said all that being
said i've never received so many death
threats and anti-semitic [ __ ] in my life
a lot of conservatives really really
really hate jews
i love how people take like issue with
that when literally
at most of these rallies
specifically the tiki torch one they're
chanting jews will not replace us it's
like literally part of their
platform that's right uh quartering said
those threats were just edgy jokes ethan
chill you didn't actually see what i was
referring to though
um
so
cool
um
he really it's so sad dude conservatives
got triggered over jokes
i told and mass reported me i got banned
for a week and the episode was removed
if only they cared about dead kids as
much as they do jokes so i want to say
sorry sorry y'all are such pathetic
snowflakes [ __ ] the nra and [ __ ] abbott
courtney said someone should bomb them
right
i mean you said it should report that
tweet this i can't believe you just said
that yo we should report that tweet
that's actually a terroristic threat
yeah i'm [ __ ] my opinion i think
everyone should report this tweet
i didn't say that [ __ ] i didn't bring
that up
this man's a dangerous menace to society
yeah i mean there's enough unstable
people who follow quartering that might
take that seriously right
true
jeez
um god i didn't realize he responded to
me so much
holy [ __ ] i was criticizing the police
for taking 77 minutes to respond to go
inside and save the kids
he said bro you shut you said we should
someone should b word the nra building
seriously this is nuts um
okay
is he defending the police being outside
for 77 minutes
okay
hey quartering more
i love how he begs people to share his
videos by the way every time he posts a
new video new video please share it's
like [ __ ] nobody's sharing your [ __ ]
live in front of 35 000 viewers ethan
klein called on people to b word the nra
violence against governor abbott he's of
course talking about saying putting a
stick in his wheel
it's [ __ ] insane
and going outside ted cruz house and
firing blanks
i was a little worried about that part
too i don't know if that was that's what
got us
um
i feel like that's
mild you think so
video has 15 ads and he received no
strike
i mean it got demonetized pretty fast
and then
then it got removed like soon after that
this man's thumbnails are so crazy
how what does she have to do with it
that i was we were talking before the
show and just like he has to include
that like that
triggered lib meme woman is in almost
all of his things it's been decades yeah
it was like 2014 or something yeah these
people are [ __ ] like epic memers i
mean this has been decades you guys and
people still i mean that's just
embarrassing for him
the first minute of that video was just
one long epic meme edit
we could look at it
oh i want to see it it's such a funny
epic meme at it too and then a new video
the title is ethan klein should be
banned from youtube immediately
it's council culture
he's already been reported to the fbi
okay well i'm reporting you to the fbi
for being a meanie
and that tweet by the way i'm reporting
that to the fbi i'm reporting it to the
texas department of uh
state public safety i'm reporting you to
oh my god his thumbnails is crazy
i'm already taking my pants off
by the way [ __ ] out of your eyeballs
this is like the cutest
this is like the cutest sweetest picture
i've ever seen of pimple
looks like the filter on where did he
even find that yeah that's not real is
it
his honesty it's probably real i don't
know it's on tim's seeking arrangement
by the way he
did he's such a psycho he includes ela
with a gun
and yeah my eyes are i'm coming from my
eyes
and then more with the susan thing which
again i personally think is just like
anti-semitic dog call i really i don't
see any other way to interpret it
but wait now you did get banned i got
banned so what
what was susan oh
um he's she's signing shining a light on
me like the police so she's down okay
maybe i take it back one quarter maybe
it's not an anti-semitic i'll call him
this yeah i just need to be showing
susan mad at you he she he's showing
based susan yeah right so
i'm rewinding that comment thank you uh
will smith
so yeah that first video is called ethan
klein rages at tim pool and paralyzed
people
just generally again god i can't stand
people that are paralyzed he's talking
about my i guess he's talking about my
tweet
again i'm not i'm not raging against
paralyzed people just greg abbott
the second one is really raging against
god for you know failing
okay
in the title the first ones below that
ethan client suspended by youtube and
did h3 podcast host lie about donating
fifty thousand dollars uh yep
definitely that's honestly just
disgusting he's just asking questions
that wasn't an accusation that was a
question like so [ __ ] disgusting that
whole
building up that [ __ ] it's just
nauseating it's so gross and that's the
thumbnail with susan in it
so say what you will about me and stuff
but saying i lied about donating is just
so [ __ ] pathetic
you've got to be a hotter topic than
brie larson at this point right like
there's oh you think so god i think i
think you're definitely i think he has
an ethan klein
well apparently he's doing [ __ ]
contributes on your
face i have nearly 50 can i get a
tribute
i think i deserve it after so many
videos idiotic statement oh wow so many
people triggered uh no it's just you
dude you see you retweeted it
oh he did no uh ashley retweeted it
actually saint claire oh that that dummy
ashley sinclair
awesome
look around do you see anyone that's not
like
down the meme hole that's actually angry
about this
no
here's the intro quartering made against
he really put some time and effort into
this man
okay he's proud of it too you can tell
let's see
i removed the footage of they got us the
incident yeah big protists outside the
nra meeting which was good
[Applause]
[Music]
oh he's he he's calling her a walrus bro
have you looked in the mirror
have you looked in the mirror you were a
[ __ ] beast dude
you are literally an unfuckable like
vile your wife won't even touch you bro
she goes to pizza without you
like you are so vile dude it's just like
so crazy that you're calling her
a seal or walrus or whatever the [ __ ]
that was
also i love animals let's be honest i
don't like the cruelty that happens to
animals
what why did he pull that cliff that's
what i'm saying this is
this is it's art it's art exactly
uh you know
uh experimental cinema he says he
doesn't like animals yet
it's film noir but he says he likes
animals yet
yeah cam said it's a jeremy.exe video
yeah this guy's definitely
but mine are lit
try to make a little sense this should
okay i don't i like animals okay
pigs and cows and stuff
do we have any insight into what they're
actually talking about there at the nra
meeting that's today in texas
[Applause]
also this whole presumption like can you
imagine these
these snowflakes were angry about 19
kids being murdered like oh what [ __ ]
losers no what losers these people are
angry about this come on triggered much
these are beautiful creatures that i
love
let's systematically
every single one of those [ __ ]
[Music]
wow
that was an old yeah epic last night
right there
[ __ ] was hilarious
how long is this
it goes on for a long time
this is all just the intro too this is
not the full video
this just proves really how talentless
he is
i mean
if this is his best effort this is some
sad [ __ ]
this is like first project in editing's
class
let's systematically
every single one of those [ __ ]
[Music]
so nobody bombed the building all right
you said bomb i take that back thank you
well well well i was gonna take saturday
off and i'll probably only do two videos
today and i appreciate everyone
that's a lot
two videos
i love them
break from your 15 daily videos it just
it shows how much effort these truly
take from him
i love the cutaway when the when the
montage finally finishes and he's just
like
he's in a nice little side angle i
snapped i was only going to do that i
went off boy he's taking saturday off
man only two videos that made like no
sense dude thank you
well well well got him saturday off we
got him boys videos stay and i
appreciate everyone
tuning in on the holiday weekend i'll be
taking the dogs
to go play right after this video but uh
i don't care if you go to yeah so if you
go to around two minutes and 10 seconds
i don't care bro what you do so he has
that minute intro he talks for about 45
seconds and then you said four minutes i
know two minutes at two minutes ten
seconds
so after his 45 seconds of talking this
is what you're gonna get i'm gonna go
walk my dogs after this video
don't care bro
just uh in the drain
[Music]
and uh before i get into this hilarious
meltdown this meltdown
is brought to you by
yeah boy
raid shadow legends oh my god this video
is sponsored this outrage this outrage
this domestic terrorist ethan klein oh
hold that thought a brought to you by
rage shadow legend he says that like
repulsive comments before this and then
uh wait let me go back and watch the
lead up that's good uh i like he's gonna
probably you know in front of 40 000
people
uh telling someone to go to the
convention
thank you
is that was that you're getting into
this hilarious meltdown this meltdown
is brought to you by
your boy
rage shadow legends check this out you
can tell he's embarrassed
yeah boy
well you're so embarrassing
you clearly care so much
about it like
you didn't just do it for the sponsor
right like you actually care about this
stuff and mean what you say huge shout
out to this video sponsor that's right
it's your boy raid shadow legend how is
that yeah boy
it's not a person it's not a jeremy you
know it's not a person right
you can't say yeah boy raid shadow
legend
his meme game is
rage shadow legend has taken over
hundreds of dollars
taken over
yeah this is a two minute ad
what
two over two yo
you are such a [ __ ] sellout [ __ ] you
gotta go to the very end of this clip
though and see what he says when he
comes back sell out but it's like you're
disingenuous you [ __ ]
don't care well he wasn't gonna make a
video today yeah yeah i happen to have a
sponsor for this video that i would yes
you know he'd be [ __ ]
look how long this is what the [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] very important he really
wants you to play rage legend as well as
a ton of silver make sure you use the
link in the description anyway back to
this demectas terrace
i know ethan will watch this video so
he's probably not used to seeing
sponsored ad reads but yeah that was a
sponsor got him
um nice dude what i'm not used to
is seeing someone who's pretending to
care about something so passionately put
a [ __ ] three-minute ad for a dumb ass
the like bottom of the barrel sponsor
that's practically a meme on youtube ray
shadow legends uh
it's
wow shilling
shelling man i'm deep undercover even
when someone cares
you don't know anything about it you can
do drunk monsters
people who are sober don't tend to pee
on the floor
i'm not taking a pause to pee
the way just try the game
such a [ __ ] low life
dude um
yeah what else we got oh yeah jeremy is
literally the loathsome dung eater he is
jeremy's the lones loathsome dung eater
from elder ring you guys
that's so funny and true
yeah i have a lot of sponsors i mean
even despite all this
stuff it's nice to see people stick with
us
but um
despite all that there was a few people
that really
stood behind us deaf noodles
is really my guy
he made a brilliant video defending me
welcome folks so in friday's episode of
the years three podcasts that we're
discussing a convention uh it's a long
video but anyway i just wanted to say
thanks to deaf noodles for that
and also uh
from the young turks hassan's uncle
hassan wanted hassan was was uh said
obviously nice things uh in my sport as
well and hassan's been through this you
know
with his uh america deserved what did he
say uh ethan's in his um
oh i forget the date his community
refers to that incident by the date as
if it's like his his 911 september
something yeah it's his like 8 14 or
something yeah yeah yeah and he was like
ethan's in his uh 8 14 er right now
i think his son got it worse
i think me and hassan were talking about
the seeds and we were both expecting it
today 21 thank you chat we're all
expecting it to go all the way there
but i think it just it went to donald
trump jr and then everyone else above
him realize how dumb it is
that they didn't take the bait right
that's right
all right
but yeah really at the end of the day
it's like
tim poole
don jr
uh the guy that's like spazzing out
about pizza hut for the last month i
mean all this is really not like
it's not the brain trust of the uh
conservative movement that was leading
the charge on this not the best and
brightest it's not that there's even
anyone not no no definitely not but
yeah it's kind of the bottom well there
are some smart people they're the most
evil ones like i would say uh
what's the guy who made breitbart
[Music]
oh oh um a
former advisor to trump who got fired
for being a creative yeah uh jesus he
looks like his name yeah he looks like
terrifying looking peter navarro no not
peter navarro uh
just search founder of breitbart
steve bannon steve bannon steve bannon
was very smart and very scary
guys sick in the mind dude
anyway so hassan wanted to get
chang's chance uh
uh snap judgment on it and this is what
his reaction was
immediately he goes all right that was
ridiculous that he said that but it's
over he he flipped that way
don't go back
i time stamped it
right after you said it yeah okay
saying someone bought in that building
and literally were like they clipped it
they shipped it they were like this
should lead the discourse because
uh everything else that they were let me
let me i gotta re-click that link
to find the moment
immediately he goes all right that was
ridiculous that he said that but it's
over he he flipped that was it he
clicked they clipped it saying someone
should bother with it and literally were
like they clipped it they shipped it
they were like this should lead the
discourse because
uh everything else that they were trying
to miss direct away from
was was found out to be completely
untrue
they they went with the good guys with a
gun the police did it incredible yeah
that's what greg happened i don't even
know why they object don't they want
arms or arms everything that's
constitutional exactly and in fact i
debated not i debate it but we had a
back and forth with tim poole just
on saturday right and he said that
everybody should be allowed to have
nukes so i'm sure that he's thrilled
with what ethan cline said exactly why
not you're leaving out the context
where he said
some people think that's a bad idea
not me though not me though but some
people may think it's right and if you
think it's a problem you need to amend
the second amendment which is obviously
like impossible to do because of people
like him
so people like him
claiming that there will literally be a
civil war if they try and do that
unbelievable yeah yeah actually tim's
civil war pool is
anyway how long we've been going that's
basically all uh two hours two minutes
and 20. that's all i have to say about
that
i need to pee but we can do some light
stuff now
um
since we kind of covered all that
lots of good stuff uh
what would be a good one jeffree star
yak me
yeah he's yakking off dude you want to
set that up olivia i'm gonna go pee real
fast i mean yeah i will try my best
maybe you want to help though yeah sure
you want me to do the intro then you can
do the more recent stuff so ladies and
gentlemen i looked into this this
morning me and olivia were talking about
it and it is wild so last august uh
jeffrey filed a trademark for a bunch of
different like farm services like a
butcher house
uh what else was it
clothing breading services
and he got a bunch of backlash and he
said the reason he was doing this is so
that nobody steals his trademark and he
was basically claiming that he didn't
intend on butchering the yaks that he
has been posting on instagram and uh
you know
having them as pets naming them being
all lovey-dovey with them so he got
backlash for that and now recently
uh some [ __ ] happened and i'll pass it
to
olivia thank you
popcorn olivia
um
[Music]
yeah crazy stuff he now um
is promoting his yak meat
what
straight up av i know for real
jerky jerky
frozen me
we've got ground yak me
yeah so this album that dan's showing on
the screen these are just some of the
beautiful moments that he shared with
his yaks no calling with them and there
really are magical creatures
cam was saying that his dream is to own
a yak you were saying something like
that wasn't a cam well i would i would
love to trade places with jeffrey but i
would treat them with love and kindness
and give them kisses on the forehead and
never kill them and sell them as meat i
love them so much and i'm sad that
that's very sweet you know a lot more
comes with you you want to yack off him
cam jeffrey said that one year ago so
let's check yeah let's check in mark the
calendar i i i was watching some tick
tocks where you're saying this like
taking care of them was his mental
health
uh like was the different mental health
and everything and
he said it's helping it was mental
health yeah yeah yeah it really it it's
really awesome blowing off steam sucks
the souls of his yaks
yeah using this [ __ ]
uh what are those called um like the
bolt gun or whatever that they used to
catch a gun oh like no no no
yeah exactly flip flip coin that guy
yeah
cam can you photoshop jeffree star with
the hair of uh javier barker the dude
from country room
i need to see that oh that's right i'm
back thank you guys call it so
you know what's funny last we talked
about jeffrey and his yaks was
zach i said i'd buy zach a rolex well i
have some news for you
if you could go take a photo with him in
his yachts who do you think's been
slaughtering
these yaks oh interesting
um
i don't know how much you guys said
about it
well we pretty much explained the
backlash that jeffrey got a year ago
when he was getting patents for all the
stuff but we haven't talked about what
he did recently which is right here okay
so this is great everyone's seen that
jeffrey moved to like wyoming or
something and he's been growing yaks
and so far like up until now he's like
these are my best friends these are my
therapy animals i love my yaks they're
so beautiful
you know here he is i mean beautiful
right i mean gorgeous gentle creatures
beautiful majestic animals right
um
look at these beautiful animals
those are some yaks right there boy
yakity yak don't talk back that's it
from
talk back or i'll [ __ ] kill you
hey yucky yak don't turn me into ground
beef
so here he is with his yaks he loves him
then all of a sudden
this [ __ ] lunatic
oh did he even he put out a video saying
he wouldn't eat his yachts so this was a
year ago whenever he was getting
backlash the first time
yeah this man filter is not doing him
any favors
he cannot look worse than this in person
this filter is disturbing
i went on twitter and there's a lot of
people making up some
which i've dealt with a lot but let me
straighten out the lies and
misconceptions miss girl i recently
trademarked star yak ranch in every
single category that you could do for
raising animals um just because you want
to always protect yourself in business
so let's say market for yarn cheese
breeding butchering etc it doesn't mean
i'm doing any of those things it just
means i don't want anyone to be able to
take my trademark in those categories
which people have done before um so i'm
just protecting myself so i guess a few
stragglers are trying to spin up a fake
story that i'm doing this and i'm doing
that y'all
relax when i'm laying on a yak and i
name them nothing is happening to them
except brushing them loving them and
feeding them anything else that y'all
making up in your head it's not real
so anyway he assured everyone he loves
these yaks
then all of a sudden
all of a sudden
this absolute lunatic
it's like serial killer behavior
tweets out this [ __ ] photo
we did a yak meet pop-up in wyoming
today
and hundreds of people came out in just
12 hours
it was beautiful to see so many locals
shop our usda inspected grass fed meat
my online store will be launching next
month this dude with no
setup
you know no easing in straight up
ground yak
there's no way he's making money from
this either the point is the cruelty he
wanted to ground these poor beautiful
creatures up and sell them no i'm sure
he would make money
not compressing to his makeup stuff
surely well dude he's selling ground
yeah do you know how much probably
effort he put into raising a pop-up it's
a yeah
he doesn't have a lot of yaks you have
to do this stuff at scale to make money
he had like 20 yachts right i'm seeing
in the uh in the chat that apparently he
just today yeah i i added that yeah
where he said i i guess he's trying to
say
some of the yaks are pets some are grown
only the bad yet they only love them
yeah if they act up um
but yak is a finite resource are we
replenishing are we getting more yaks to
slaughter what are we doing
i'd be very curious i can see how it
tastes star yak ranch
finite resource
i mean i think if they tasted good
they're probably and was affordable
there'd probably already be yaks on the
on the shelf
listen off actually let's go to his it
doesn't say the price i'm really
interested at uh how much it costs
let's see
star yak ranch baby
ready for a full tour of the yak ranch
wait where do i buy the meat
i think it was a local thing yeah i
wasn't kidding it was a pop-up yeah you
can't even but he's just killing these
poor yaks and turning them into ground
beef
ground yeah what people do to make
ground beef and i'm afraid
here's a little ad for the jerky if you
want to check that out
someone said wait you killed them i
thought you were they were your pets
since you named them
you're farming your yaks this is so
weirdly off brown why sell meat
if your makeup is vegan and cruelty free
that's actually a really good question
he responded to that in a tweet you put
out today
oh yeah yeah i have those all the
updates at the bottom okay let's go
through the doc
but uh here's jeffrey has uh you also
yak jerky so
2022 is a special year okay and while
supplies last for new customers that are
coming tomorrow you will get a bag of
free jerky
um and i cannot wait for you guys to try
this it is so yummy
hey y'all okay dude what is wrong with
you
also it goes limited supply it's like
yeah cause you killed all your yaks
there's no more yaks
i don't understand this business
decision
jeffrey's having yak for dinner
yummy
late
last night's dinner
bone and star yak ribeye oh my god
he's really teasing everybody he really
is
that's a nice ass knife
never mind that yak was on his feet last
week
he was getting brushed last week
this week he's getting eaten with some
[ __ ] truffle butter
holy [ __ ] this is just crazy twist
ride him cop hulk
um just posted
he just posted this last month queen of
the yaks actually on his way to the
slaughterhouse interestingly final
moments he's uh he needs
to re-up on his yak
jerky
yeah final moments right last photo i
wonder if like how he picks the ones
that are like going to be
you know slaughtered like if one of them
looks at him funny
beautiful flips a coin like that guy
yeah the cattle pro thing look i i eat
meat and i get it but like if you are
if they're like your pets and you know
them how can you do it that is crazy did
he get them with the intention that they
would be his pets that's that's what the
whole
yeah he claims these are different yaks
but
i just don't understand
getting a yak farm and saying i love all
of them they're my pets and then making
the decision to start killing them
that's the that's what's so crazy about
all this
uh here's more snow queen realness yeah
she's dead actually she's dead
we ate her last year
i turned her into a coat too
update jeffrey says the yaks
he killed aren't the same ones as his
pets okay thank god
oh my god girl when the beauty industry
was at its height and we'd hop on here
every day and
but i do want to say well this dude
looks like he's about to go like uh
figure skating right now
giving me tanya harding
or what was wasn't there a will farrell
movie about ice skating
blades of glory he looks like jimmy he's
giving me blades of glory john heater's
character elsa on ice
can i just say with peace and love and i
am just talking about jeffrey
this is one of the weirdest looking
people on the whole planet earth
his whole vi just jeffrey i'm just
talking about jeffrey can i get a
co-sign can i get an a-man i'll give you
an amen i would yes it's just the
weirdest look
i wouldn't buy yak meat from this person
just every time i see him it's like bro
you are [ __ ] just
amen super interesting look he shaves
his eyebrows
okay that's probably part yeah so he
looks kind of like haley
yeah very good very good
flip a coin yak
yes
oh we got a new one
oh the eyebrows match oh we removed the
eyebrows oh yeah always the
perfectionist that looks way crazy way
better
it's awesome
because it's me
it's gonna be something always different
right [ __ ] i'm not a hypocrite
i'm not a liar
but you don't know me i'm me [ __ ] and i
bought a ranch
months later the idea evolved i educated
myself
where the food i was putting into my
body came from and [ __ ] i didn't give a
[ __ ] about myself hi i ate mcdonald's
every day i was promoting taco bell like
it was [ __ ] chanel
disgusting i'm so disappointed in myself
i mean hello i got sponsored by taco
bell i did so many videos with fast food
and i'm like that's just not me anymore
[ __ ] i'm i'm a different person
um so oh shut the [ __ ] up if they came
offering money you take it in a
heartbeat nobody wants to work with you
anymore because you're like people know
you're a creep now right didn't he get
cancelled for being a weirdo
like racism and scheming he's been
canceled a million times yeah
obviously hasn't really impacted him
i mean his s moved to wyoming so
he got chased out of the state
you think anyone wants to live in
wyoming
no
they move there because they get chased
out of other states i would say you're
being insensitive to our fans in wyoming
but
yeah and i guarantee you ask them to say
no i don't want to live here
can't leave
you know what's the population of
wyoming two people you can get a lot of
land jeffrey
and his yak
and it's going down every day less yeah
every day
i i think 500 000 people that actually
is like only like half a million people
yeah 580
peace and love to my friends in
wyoming
kanye lives there
it's the place to go when you're
canceled kanye was also chased out of
the state right
yeah it's just jeffree star kanye and a
couple of yaks
no i'm not a liar
i started raising yaks over a year ago
and i still have 120 pets and the only
yaks that you guys have ever seen on
social media are my pets any tag with a
name
is my pet people are so i think if you
just don't like me in general you're
just hopping on this thing today maybe
it's memorial day weekend you're bored
but i'm like girl stop me up in your
hand don't see why it's funny that
you're all of a sudden posting ground
yak and people are
[ __ ] a little like what weirded out
by that
um
so i just pulled up
our channel analytics
oh no we have a huge population in
wyoming no
wait hold on this can't be right tell me
there's literally none there's zero
people from wyoming it listed elicit by
state
the lowest state listed is south dakota
wyoming isn't on this list
does it do you need to expect maybe
export that's what i thought showing top
50 results there's 50 states
maybe includes caught like uh
did it get squeezed yeah maybe it got
squeezed out by like uh 52 puerto rico
oh district of columbia
yeah
so just so it's probably 51 and it's
it's like
it's below the fold
okay thank god [ __ ] wyoming
no i'm just kidding but that's pretty
funny
so apparently not many people angry
wyoming be like hello hello hello
[Laughter]
i'm so angry angry angry angry
oh somebody chat i'm from wyoming you're
from wyoming but do you still live there
he exactly from
wyoming is literally just like the empty
plains with a with a tumbleweed blowing
through it another person i grew up in
wyoming you grew up there but
you got out man sure jeffrey went there
you escaped explain that
don't make no kind of sense
oh here we
here we go i'm in wyoming and i want to
live here but i still love you ethan
okay thank you
to you to that quinn our wonderful we
love you
god bless wyoming and the good people of
wyoming quinn's a yak
i'm going to end up in wyoming something
terrible is going to happen i'm going to
end up living there watch
it's really like all jokes aside it's
really beautiful yeah it's very pretty
and uh i mean i imagine the land is
cheap because it's so empty like 50
grand can get you like 100 acres oh my
god it is beautiful the [ __ ]
operations
look how beautiful wyoming is yeah let's
go
i've been holding it in wyoming is my
favorite state oh my god yes i love
wyoming i am passionate about wyoming
what have you got to say about life this
is um i grew up going there
during the summer we would go to like a
ranch and we would just do like
honestly really country [ __ ] but it was
really fun like it's it's so much fun i
love it and it's beautiful
start
in the air and we whip our tallow sun
there ain't no minorities out here
and we pray every sunday
sorry
sorry about that
it is gorgeous out there wow
[Applause]
this shed is popular
is it just one shed it's the only place
yeah the only building in wyoming
i don't even know if they have an air
wyoming is actually uh
surprisingly diverse there's another one
this shed is just
this year's city hall this year is where
our governor lives that's the general
store
it's everything please here's where our
senators and our governor work out of
it's the hospital the police station
is diverse i'm sorry i'm sorry guys uh
well i mean it ranks 44th
that's quite low uh
in the country but but it's still
more diverse than uh what's the least
diverse state uh west virginia
come on down to west virginia boy
followed by maine and then vermont and
then new hampshire uh a lot of new
england uh on here actually
you have to get yourself [ __ ] goddamn
forever the west oh
where's mass actually i want to go to
wyoming it looks absolutely gorgeous
let's go to wyoming dude dude i could be
the richest person in that state
probably
not jeffrey's there
[Laughter]
it might be the most per capita richest
uh population with those two there
yo we got one beautiful [ __ ] out here
boy there's just a hundred pictures of
this one beautiful shed you've all been
to the shed
welcome to wyoming you all been to the
shed yet
i always thought well it's beautiful
wyoming had the coolest national quarter
do you remember when they put like
different states on the back of the
quarter i do remember that that i used
to collect those and wyoming was like
the coolest one in my opinion man i
haven't done it i haven't held a quarter
in years but yeah i love those beautiful
quarters that's the u.s
steak headquarters right there
what the [ __ ] is this shed
that's the capital okay wait i'm gonna
do wyoming shed
vpn
oh
what antler
because they shed their antlers about
cabin
oh you've seen our cabin what it is
beautiful
that does look nice
i'm getting sold on wyoming honestly
it's beautiful man
it's quite beautiful let's look up
wyoming real estate
let's [ __ ] go to wyoming that should
be their trip that should be their
advertising
[Laughter]
wait hold on let's go
can you someone go to
zillow
and go to the whole state of wyoming and
sort by most expensive
property on the market i just want to
look from the top down and see what i
can get it's like 50 grand
high to low in wyoming 50 million
dollars let's see what that looks like
what the hell is that not just the whole
state yeah it's the whole state huge
piece of property what is this
whoa 50 acres 50 acres imagine your own
50 year old jackson hall boy that's
where they all live right isn't that
where uh
kanye lives
dude
he lives in cody oh
okay so it's just a massive [ __ ] lot
this one for 20 million is only one
that's an actual home let's see it
by the way ethan side note yes since i
happen to have pulled up the channel
analytics here and looking at uh our
audience by
state you know what the sec the first i
do not surprising is california do you
know what the second is i do
and we love our team dude it's texas you
gotta be careful
it's a huge state but we love our texans
that actually but it's it beats new york
by a decent margin which i find a little
surprising
we love our texans why
mm-hmm
population of texas
they have a lot of people a lot of folks
living out there in texas
one of the most popular states
28 million versus new york i'm the first
jew on stage 8 million so that explains
that
i mean it has like four times the
population
or is that a city wait that's
state
oh 20 million in this state
there you go
oh
ooh
show me that 20 million property i want
to see that i sent in a discord oh
all right let's see what the most
expensive house in wyoming looks like
okay 20 million
let's take a look here
that this looks like a resort
yeah it looks like a hotel
it's very nice
wait that it says four bedroom that's a
four bedroom house
yeah possible and i mean 10 000 square
foot is big but it's not
like 20 million big
is this in like
is it like in yellowstone or something
well it's on 48 acres okay there you go
that explains it
i see
all right cool
anyway
moving on
so jeffrey's eating is the axe
funny stuff
funny stuff
and so i ate my yak you want me to read
this one what is this these are his
tweets uh about the situation he says i
guess some people forgot that it's okay
to change your mind or evolve [ __ ]
you're eating your pets
people are so [ __ ] weird it's a trip
if you're losing sleep nobody's losing
sleep they just think it's funny
i guarantee nobody's losing sleep it's
time for some self-reflection the
world's so dark and ugly why project
your anger at me bro it's just funny man
you opened a yak farm and then you're
eating them it's awesome
well
i'm sure he is getting a lot of genuine
hate from people for this
i don't think i know we just like find
it hilarious you think people are losing
sleep over jeffrey eating his yeah
people lose sleep over everything
losing sleep tossing and turning
thinking about jeffy
but if you go to tick tock and search
jeffree star right now i guarantee you
there's like a million okay prove it
trying to cancel him it's some
cold-blooded [ __ ] i mean
what he's doing eating is bad
it is it is
our country is trying to take women's
rights away and there's already so much
hate on the internet every single moment
there's no way people are actually
concerned about me supplying my local
community with food i've known donated
over a thousand pounds of meat to
shelters that's actually great that is
very nice
i don't think he's selling it if he's
donating it that's not
his yaks are literally worthless he just
gives away their bodies
to whoever will take this
he hates them that much no but it's nice
he's donating it
well he's still going stop using the
same regurgitated quote from last year
when i said all my yaks are pets they
are
but months later i learned how healthy
yak meat is hashtag yak by the way let's
get a trend
[Laughter]
and i started to appreciate learning
where my food comes from educate
yourself and not immediately laugh such
a comic book villain like i can't
i don't i want to say that i like him
but
i i do appreciate that he exists to
consistently be goofy as hell like this
hashtag yak
when i stopped eating fast food and
started to care about my body more i
realized i wanted to take what i was
doing to a different avenue as well and
it's been a beautiful experience not
eating horrible meat from farmers that
give animals growth hormone and
disgusting additives okay
oh my god he's still going i can't do
this guys
oh this was interesting new york times
is calling out dink doink
he literally
committed a massive fraud
on his fans and like nobody [ __ ]
talks about it
well the new york times finally someone
acknowledged it
um
they've talked about
this isn't it yeah that looks like the
wrong article
all right well anyway thank you guys for
watching everybody
uh new york times calls out dink doink
it's finally mainstreaming new york
times is mainstreaming
the crypto crisis
they state that logan paul
was all in on dink doink
and after it plummeted to a fraction of
a cent in a month's time paul faced
online backlash because he failed to
mention some relevant information
including
he and the project creator are friends
and they came up with the idea together
macho broken though
you should get the sound bite of t
martin or pro syndicate whoever saying i
found this great site
throwback he also received a large
allocation of dink point dink doing
coins when it launched
that's crazy
he said i don't know what went wrong
with that in an interview that's the
project from hell i just wipe my hands
of it i'm sure you do
let's see if that holds up in court i
wipe my hands of losing my fans yeah i'd
love to once again fraud
wouldn't that be nice
yeah where's that article though it's
pretty cool to see it it's up there it's
in the doc in the yeah check it out i
mean it was like a main oh come on
here if i refresh real fast you guys can
see it see
ready
screenshot this ready screenshot this
you guys ready
go go go go get it if you're really
slick you can hit refresh and then the
stop and it it'll stop before it loads
the uh
you know it takes a few tries but
i'm stopping as fast you gotta keep
hitting it you gotta keep it
oh
oh i think you had it but then you hit
refresh again
you can do it i can't do it oh i did
it there you go
we've hacked the [ __ ] system dude
yeah so this is like a big thing they
did how influencers hype crypto without
disclosing their financial ties
logan paul paul pierce and other
celebrities have promoted risky and
obscure digital currencies sometimes
failing to mention their conflict of
interest that's putting it nicely
so yeah
no comment from him by the way
but they think the week is my favorite
coin
wait
i thought you said it's a project from
hell
yeah yeah
[Music]
is there a sound bite of him saying that
because i'd like to work that into this
song
saying it's the project from hell
no i have to
put your hands in the air
come on everybody
um
[Music]
say this out loud but jeffree star is
selling
guys you can get it's not too late to
get in on ding dong ground floor guys
it's worth 100 trillionth of a cent guys
now is the time
to get in the freaking blueberry
all right there's a bunch there's stuff
left but let's move it on let's save it
for another day
okey-dokey well we've said it all we've
done it all
oh here's a post
about it
logan paul's crypto scam is down 97
since launch who would have thought
oh this is us in wyoming i love that
just
saying
i love that i wouldn't be there
see i'm even wearing the right shirt for
it too
you sure are buddy did you put the rolex
on his wrist
no i can do that though yeah you would
get come on that photo doesn't have his
role it's embarrassing
you want me to thank you
thank you sir
anyway guys thank you so much for
tuning in it's nice to see
that everyone is here watching we're
back love to see you guys thanks for all
your support
thanks for all the subbies thanks for
all the gifting subbies
and thanks just everyone for watching
you know it means a lot to see all y'all
supporting us and uh
well what can i say we're not going
anywhere we have to be good boys though
for three months because that's how long
it takes for a strike to expire
our last one already expired by the way
so
we're at one we're at one
so we've got to be good boys for the
next three months and then it's off the
r and then it's back to b threats
nope
just kidding of course
um
so we'll be back on a wednesday
for a little off the rails what do you
guys think about that huh you want to
come to my car
no
oh thank you
[Laughter]
good one all right guys we love you
thank you so much really i'm students
i'm just so happy to see all y'all
coming out and enjoying the show and
watching us really means a lot um
feels good it really does so thank you
guys family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family you
can just family you just
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
family family family
family family family family now family
family family family family family
family and family